Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 28, Applied Artificial Intelligence. Take it away, Patrick. Wow, nice. All right, so this episode we're going to skip the news because we've got a lot to talk about.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 28 期，应用人工智能。帕特里克，开始吧。哇，不错。好的，这一期我们就不谈新闻了，因为我们要聊的内容很多。
And then also, I'm not sure whether everybody likes the news, and by the time we release it, it's not always freshest news. It's not new, it's old. So it's much more just our discussion. But we have a lot of feedback, so I want to talk about that. So first of all, thank you everybody for sending us feedback
另外，我不确定大家是否都喜欢新闻，而且等我们发布的时候，新闻往往已经不新鲜了。那不是新消息，是旧闻。所以这一期更多是我们自己的讨论。但我们收到了很多反馈，所以我想谈谈这些。首先，感谢大家通过电子邮件、Google Plus 帖子评论、还有我不知道，反正就是我们博客上的许多评论给我们发送反馈。
via email, comments on the google plus post comments on our I don't know many comments on our blog really yeah one thing we we well at least I haven't been really following the g plus page I've kind of abandoned that in favor of the g plus community which I feel like kind of has a better ui so definitely post on the community you know we've gotten a lot of posts about you know new languages a lot of posts about new languages like Haskell. Well, not new languages, but the languages that we haven't covered. That's right. And so we definitely take
真的，有一件事我们，至少我，并没有真正关注 G Plus 页面，为了 G Plus 社区，我已经放弃了那个页面，我觉得社区的界面更好，所以一定要在社区发帖，你知道我们收到了很多关于新语言的帖子，很多关于像 Haskell 这样的新语言的帖子。好吧，不是新语言，而是我们还没涉及过的语言。没错。所以我们肯定会认真对待这些建议，
those seriously, and there will be definitely a Haskell episode this season. Where a season is an indeterminate number of episodes. Yeah, actually, we should probably figure out how long the season goes. It's our gut. I don't know how they do it in the movies and um it's arbitrary it's arbitrary so anyways but thank you for your feedback yeah we really appreciate it and and sorry we don't always reply to everybody we're you know got busy
这一季肯定会有一期关于 Haskell 的节目。其中“一季”是指不确定集数的节目。是的，其实我们应该确定一下这一季要持续多久。这是我们的直觉。我不知道电影里是怎么做的，嗯，这很随意，很随意，所以无论如何，感谢你们的反馈，是的，我们真的很感激，抱歉我们不能总是回复每个人，你知道我们有忙碌的电子邮件收件箱，
crowded email inboxes like but we do read them we do see them we do appreciate even the people who tell us we're wrong um that's okay we we don't mind yeah we appreciate constructive criticism or deconstructive criticism i don't appreciate it but it's okay we we don't mind yeah we appreciate constructive criticism or deconstructive criticism i don't appreciate it but it's okay we read it and smile a couple of people or said something like uh oh you'd be much better off listening to my podcast yeah that's one star which that's how you know you've made it yeah maybe so speaking of that i checked and we have 107 as of this recording podcast reviews in itunes nice thank you all i know not all of you listen via itunes or ios devices and so i know that's not nearly representative of the total
但我们确实读了，确实看到了，我们也感谢那些指出我们错误的人，嗯，没关系，我们不介意，是的，我们感谢建设性的批评，或者破坏性的批评，我不喜欢，但没关系，我们不介意，是的，我们感谢建设性的批评，或者破坏性的批评，我不喜欢，但没关系，我们读了并会心一笑，有几个人说，哦，听我的播客会好得多，是的，那是一星评价，这就是你知道你已经成功了的方式，是的，也许吧，说到这个，我查了一下，截至录制时，我们在 iTunes 上有 107 条播客评论，不错，谢谢大家，我知道你们并非都通过 iTunes 或 iOS 设备收听，所以我知道这并不能完全代表给我们爱戴的总人数，
amount of people who are giving us love but we really do appreciate that feedback we noticed actually even though we had a big break before last episode in this episode that people are still finding the podcast you know we're building up a set of topics which people are interested on so if you're new welcome yeah um but we're definitely building up people and it's growing over time and so like that's definitely keeps jason and i interested and engaged in uh recording each interval um so so uh just some stats um last month our our stats actually went down because the website was down. So if you were following our G Plus community, you knew about that.
但我们真的很感谢这些反馈，我们注意到，实际上尽管上一期和这一期之间有很长的间隔，但人们仍然在发现这个播客，你知道我们正在建立一个人们感兴趣的话题集，所以如果你是新听众，欢迎，是的，嗯，但我们确实在积累听众，而且随着时间的推移在增长，所以这确实让杰森和我保持兴趣并参与到每一期的录制中，所以，嗯，只是一些统计数据，上个月我们的统计数据实际上下降了，因为网站宕机了。所以如果你关注了我们的 G Plus 社区，你就知道这件事。
We had an issue with our ISP that took a couple weeks or took a week or so to resolve. But before that, we were hitting 1.2 terabytes a month of bandwidth. So you guys are definitely downloading a lot of episodes. So which one of you is downloading just like a thousand of them yeah well according to feed burner we have over 2 000 unique subscribers nice so totally awesome you know definitely uh you know we had 2 000 subscribers and a hundred uh comments so a lot of you out there if you're shy come on don't don't uh don't be shy tell us uh what you think we could do to make the show better. A couple of people have given us advice like don't do the news every time because it starts to get old.
我们的 ISP 出了点问题，花了几周或一周左右的时间才解决。但在那之前，我们的带宽达到了每月 1.2 TB。所以你们肯定下载了很多集。那么你们中到底是谁下载了上千集呢？嗯，根据 FeedBurner 的数据，我们有超过 2000 名独立订阅者，不错，太棒了，你知道，我们有 2000 名订阅者和 100 条评论，所以你们很多人，如果害羞的话，来吧，别害羞，告诉我们你认为我们可以做些什么来让节目变得更好。有几个人给了我们建议，比如不要每次都做新闻，因为它开始变得陈旧了。
And we take that advice very seriously. Yeah, and there's a fine balance there. We don't listen to everybody's advice. No offense. We do appreciate the advice. Feel free to share. We do try to listen to if a lot of people are saying something. But, you know, this is Jason and my podcast.
我们非常认真地对待这些建议。是的，这之间有一个微妙的平衡。我们不会听取每个人的建议。别介意。我们确实很感激这些建议。欢迎随时分享。如果很多人都在说某件事，我们确实会尝试去听。但是，你知道，这是杰森和我的播客。
Horrible grammar. I'm sorry. But this is our podcast. And so, like, you know, at some level, we want to keep it what we want to be. Like, we need to keep doing it, right? So we have to do something that we like doing. Yeah. So, you know, don't feel, like, offended if you have, like, oh, I really want to talk about this or that.
语法太糟糕了。抱歉。但这是我们的播客。所以，你知道，在某种程度上，我们想保持我们想要的样子。就像，我们需要继续做下去，对吧？所以我们必须做一些我们喜欢做的事情。是的。所以，你知道，如果你有，比如，哦，我真的很想谈谈这个或那个，而杰森和我对此并不感兴趣，不要感到被冒犯。那么，你知道，我们可能不会谈论它，因为我们不会投入热情，我们想对我们所做的事情充满热情，是的，这绝对是某种融合，既从社区获取反馈，制作出尽可能好的节目，同时也做一些我们知识范围内的事情，并保持自我，所以这是一个微妙的界限，但我们确实想走这条线，因为你们的反馈让节目变得好多了。是的，所以感谢所有 iTunes 的爱。如果你喜欢这些，请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。
And Jason and I aren't really into it. Then, you know, we may not talk about it because, you know won't give it passion we want to be passionate about what we do yeah definitely it's sort of a blend between you know taking getting feedback from the community and making the best possible show from the community but also you know doing something that we're knowledgeable and staying true to ourselves too and so yeah it's a it's a fine line but we definitely that's the line we want to walk because your feedback has made the show much, much better. Yeah, so thank you for all the iTunes love. If you're into such things, please rate us on iTunes.
那太棒了。我们真的很感激。这让我们感觉很好。所以我们的一位听众尼尔写信推荐了一个他喜欢的电视节目。我以为我会得到一个很棒的科幻推荐，但这在某些方面可能更酷。他推荐了一个烹饪节目，《美国测试厨房》(America's Test Kitchen)。我确实看过这个节目很多次。
That'd be awesome. We do appreciate it. It makes us feel good. So one of our listeners, Neil, wrote in to recommend a TV show that he appreciates. I thought I was going to get like an awesome sci-fi recommendation, but this maybe in some ways is cooler. He recommended a cooking show, America's Test Kitchen. And I have actually watched this show a number of times.
我不是每一集都看，但这在 PBS 上播出，也就是公共广播电台之类的。每个人在当地都有不同的频道，至少在美国是这样。如果你住在其他国家，也许可以在网上看到。因为我们确实，杰森也和我分享了统计数据，你们很多人在美国。如果你住在其他国家，也许可以在网上看到。因为我们确实，杰森也和我分享了统计数据。你们很多人在美国，但也有很多人在收听，而且不在美国。
I don't watch it every episode, but this comes on PBS, so Public Broadcasting Station or whatever. Everybody's got their own different one locally, at least here in the United States. And maybe it's online if you live in another country. Because we do actually, Jason shared the stats with me as well, a lot of you are in the United States. And maybe it's online if you live in another country. Because we do actually, Jason shared the stats with me as well. A lot of you are in the United States, but there are a lot of people who listen and aren't in the United States.
这也真的很棒。你想让我用德语打招呼吗？我要查一下。不。好吧。我要查一下。所以当他查的时候，我来告诉你关于《美国测试厨房》的事。所以尼尔说他们试图为烹饪开发一种算法。
And that's really awesome as well. Do you want me to say hello in German? I'm going to look it up. No. Okay. I'm going to look it up. So while he looks it up, I'm going to tell you about America's Test Kitchen. So Neil said that they kind of try to develop an algorithm for cooking.
我同意。我认为他们，你知道，这不是一个技术节目，但如果你曾经看过烹饪节目，就像，啊，加一点这个，加一点那个，这些人试图说，让我们尝试五种不同的方式来裹鸡肉，并真正确定人们喜欢酥脆且厚度适中的表皮。所以我们可以加入什么，即使它看起来不太合理，也能真正让它奏效？
And I agree. I think they, you know, it's not a techie show a techie show, but if you ever have watched a cooking show and it's like, ah, a pinch of this, a pinch of that, these people try to say, let's try five different ways to batter a piece of chicken and really get the – we really determine people like crispy skin that sticks good and is about medium thickness. So what can we put in, even if it doesn't make a lot of sense, that really makes that work?
他们尝试各种组合，而不是仅仅，你知道，你会知道什么时候它是好的。所以我很欣赏这一点。这很有趣。所以谢谢你，尼尔。我还没看过那个节目，但我一定会去看看。是的，我的意思是，我们所有人都得吃饭。所以这意味着我们中至少有些人有时会做饭。
And they try to try various combinations as opposed to just kind of, you know, you'll know when it's good. So I do appreciate that. That's kind of interesting. So thank you, Neil. I haven't seen that show yet, but I'll definitely check it out. Yeah, I mean, all of us have to eat. So that means some of us at least cook some of the time.
所以绝对很有趣。是的，所以我们的两个，排名第二和第三的最受欢迎的 Programming Throwdown 观看国家分别是日本和德国。不错。所以向我们的日本朋友说 konnichiwa，向我们的德国朋友说 hallo。你为什么笑？不，我笑是因为它和英语太像了。起初，我以为谷歌在跟我玩游戏，因为它不是一个实际的搜索结果。我输入了德语的 hello，它直接跳转到了谷歌翻译。
So definitely interesting. Yeah, so our two, the two number, number two and three most popular countries for programming throwdown viewership are Japan and Germany respectively. Nice. So konnichiwa to our Japanese friends and hallo to our German friends. Why are you laughing? No, I'm laughing because it's so close to English. At first, I thought that Google was playing games with me because it wasn't an actual search result. I put hello in German and it went straight to Google Translate.
它只是说了 hello。我以为出了什么大问题。好吧。所以，也许我们今天可以谈谈机器翻译。是的。多么贴切。所以谢谢你们在世界各地收听的朋友。如果杰森说得不好，请原谅他。所以特拉维斯写信来讨论。
And it just said hello. And I thought that something had gone horribly wrong. Okay. So, maybe we'll talk about machine translation today. Yeah. How apropos. So thank you guys out there listening all over the world. And please forgive Jason if he said that poorly. So Travis wrote in to discuss.
他有很多好的评论和观点。但他也在说，你知道，嘿，你们有很多集节目。我正在听其中的一些。但是，你知道，很难理解，比如当我有一个新项目时，我应该用什么语言编写它，这是杰森和我讨论过的一点，就像，是的，你知道，这是一个难题，但有时，你知道，我不完全同意你的观点，但我的观点是，确实，有时你会陷入困境，
He had a number of good comments and points. But he was also saying, you know, like, hey, you guys got a lot of episodes. I'm listening to some of them. But, you know, it's kind of hard to, to you know understand like when i have a new project like what what language should i write it in and this is something like jason and i discussed a little and it's like yeah you know it's a hard question um and but sometimes you know and um i don't i almost stare your point but my point is like it is true like sometimes you can get bogged down
试图进行过多的分析，比如我想做什么？我们确实涵盖了很多语言。我们没有一个很好的格式来涵盖语言的每一个应用作为剧集，让你看到你的选择。就像生活中的许多事情一样，解决问题的方法不止一种。有些方法比其他方法更好，但在两个选择之间，即使是权威人士、谷歌、互联网或其他什么人说，你知道这种方式是最好的，你应该总是这样做，那大部分只是因为那些人太固执己见，因为对你来说，最好的方式完全取决于你自己，如果你知道一种
though like trying to figure out too much analysis like what do I want to do? And we do cover a lot of languages. There's not really a good format for us to like cover every like application of the language as episodes that you can then see your choices. And like many things in life, there's more than one way to solve the problem. Some ways are better than other ways, but between two choices, like even if the man or Google or the internet or whatever says that like you know this way is the best like you should always do it this way that's just over opinionated people for the most part because for you the best way is dependent on you completely if you know a
语言，并且没有明显的理由说明它为什么不能用那种语言工作，你知道，去尝试吧，也许那对你来说是最好的学习体验，就是尝试用那种语言，这通常是新语言被创造出来的方式，你知道人们发现现有语言的不足，但绝对是，这就像你的个人情况，而且我认为我经常陷入这种困境，就像你上网，你想买一条裤子。天哪，这条裤子有三星评价。你知道，哦，它也很糟糕。但就像，等等，等等，等一下。
language and there isn't an obvious reason why it won't work in that language you know go for it like maybe that can be the best learning experience for you is to try it in that language you know go for it like maybe that can be the best learning experience for you is to try it in that language and that's often how new languages get created um you know people find shortfalls in what's there but definitely it's like your personal situation and like don't and i think i get stuck in this uh rut a lot like you go online you're like looking up like i want to buy a you know of pants. Oh man, this pair of pants has like three star reviews. You know, like, oh, it's terrible too. But it's like, wait, wait, hang on, hang on a second.
首先，它只是一条裤子。这真的没关系。其次，那些人可能和我非常不同。如果他们都谈论合身度。但我不知道他们的体型可能和我的体型非常不同。所以，那种建议并不总是适用于我，所以对互联网和互联网上的建议有一个普遍的警告，你知道，记住要持保留态度，因为每个人的情况都不同，是的。
First of all, it's just a pair of pants. Like, it doesn't really matter. Second of all, it's like, those people could be very different than me. Like, if they all talk about the fit. But I don't know what they, like, their body type may be very different than my body type. So, like, that advice doesn't always apply to me so just a general you know big caveat to the internet in general and advice on the internet you know just remember take it with a grain of salt because everybody's situation is different yeah
绝对是这样，所以你有什么想法？是的，所以帕特里克说得完全正确，你应该直接投入其中，选择一种你觉得舒服的语言，或者如果这是一个你为了好玩而做的项目，选择一种学习起来会很有趣的语言，然后投入其中。你要么会学到为什么那是一个糟糕的选择，这真的很有趣，要么最有可能的是，你会用那种语言做得很好，它可能不是最高效的，你知道，但你可以在任何语言中完成几乎任何事情。所以我唯一想补充的是，考虑你的受众，对吧？
definitely so what are your thoughts yeah so Patrick's absolutely right you should just dive into it pick a language that you know you feel comfortable with or one that would be fun to learn if it's if it's a project you're doing for fun and jump into it you'll either learn why that was a bad choice which is really interesting to find out or most likely you will do fine in that language it might not be the most efficient you know but but you'll get you can get almost anything done in any language for the most part. So the only thing I would want to add is think about your audience, right?
所以，嗯，两件事。第一，考虑你的受众。所以如果你想让它成为一个网络应用，那么 JavaScript 显然会扮演很重要的角色。如果你想让它成为某种服务器、后端之类的东西，为成千上万的客户服务，那么你会想使用 C++ 或 Go 或 Java
So, well, two things. One, think about your audience. So if you're wanting this to be a web app, then JavaScript obviously is gonna play a pretty heavy role. If you're wanting this to be some kind of server, backend kind of thing that's gonna serve thousands of customers, then you'll want to use C++ or Go or Java
或类似的东西，对吧？所以你必须稍微考虑一下你的目标受众。另一件事是，你知道，要知道你可以让用两种不同语言编写的两个程序进行通信。你知道，我们在 IDL 那一期讨论过 Thrift 和协议缓冲区之类的东西，
or something similar, right? So you have to think a little bit about your target audience. The other thing is, you know, know that you can have two programs written in two different languages communicate. You know, we talked in our IDL episode about, you know, Thrift and protocol buffers and things
所以你知道，如果结果你用 Lisp 编写它，假设现在突然你需要一个 Web 前端，你总是可以用 JavaScript 做那部分，然后使用 Thrift RPC 或其他东西来与你的其他程序通信，所以是的，不要太担心选择语言，只要选择一个你想学的或者你最舒服的，取决于你编程的环境。如果你需要快速完成某件事，那么选择你最舒服的语言，你应该会做得很好。
like that so you know if it turns out you write it in Lisp let's say and now all of a sudden you need a web front-end you can always do that part in JavaScript and then use Thrift RPC or something else to talk about it to talk to to your to your other programs so yeah don't be too worried about picking a language just pick one that you want to learn or one that you're most comfortable with, depending on the type of setting you're programming. And if you need to get something done quick, then pick the language you're most comfortable with, and you should be just fine.
所以我们之前讨论过，所以我不会在这里过度重复，但也要记住，我们很多人编写的应用程序不需要从第一天起就为数百万用户扩展。所以你总是可以随着学习的深入而开发，利用你提前学到的东西，你会听到史诗般的错误，比如你知道 Facebook 怀疑它是否应该如此沉重地实现，或者是什么，不，我想是 Dig 用 PHP 实现东西，然后只雇佣 PHP 程序员，以及这如何让他们感觉像是一个大问题，就像，嗯，但首先，他们是案例，我们之前讨论过，处于那种情况在某种程度上是好事，你有太多的用户，以至于你无法再支持流量了。
So we talked about it before, so I won't overly hash it here, but also remember that a lot of us aren't writing apps that need to scale for millions of users from day one. And so you can always develop something as you go learn using what you learn leveraging what you learned in advance and you hear about epic mistakes like you know facebook doubting whether or not maybe it should have been so heavy and implementing or what is it no i guess it was dig implementing stuff in php and then like only hiring php programmers and like how this was like they feel like a big problem for them It's like well, but first of all, they're the use case and we talked about before like being in that situation is somewhat Like good situation to be in that you have so many users that you can't support the traffic anymore
如果你是 Dig，你可以用另一种语言重写它，并且做得很好，虽然我不认为这对他们来说效果很好，但 Dig 确实得到了很多他们的，他们的，这是一个完整的事情，是的，是的，它不在这里或那里，但它的增长模型确实有缺陷，但无论如何，那是另一回事，是的，我不认为他们的语言是杀死他们的原因，不，我也不这么认为，是的，但好的，是时候介绍本期工具了，所以我的本期工具是 WebM。WebM。所以 WebM 非常棒。它正变得越来越流行。它内置于 Chrome 和 Firefox，许多现代浏览器中。基本上，它是一个完全开源、免版税、无专利的视频编码器和解码器。它是用 C++ 编写的，但有 Java 和其他绑定。
If you're dig you can just rewrite it in another language and be just fine Although I don't think that worked out so well for him but and did get other a lot of their a lot of their ass there's a whole thing about yeah yeah it's not here and there but it's growth model was fun really flawed but anyways that's for another yeah I don't think their language is what killed them no I don't think so either yeah but yeah all right time for tool of the show to the show so my tool of this show is WebM. WebM. So WebM is pretty awesome. It's becoming more and more popular. It's built into Chrome and Firefox, many of these modern browsers. Basically, it's a completely open source, royalty-free, patent-free video encoder and decoder. It's in C++, but there are Java and other bindings for it.
或者正如我们刚才讨论的，你可以有一个某种 Thrift RPC 服务器，你将视频帧传递给这个东西并获得压缩视频，等等。但 WebM 非常史诗。它比 H.264 有更好的压缩效果。所以对于那些不太熟悉的人，如果你去，你知道，YouTube，假设你观看一个视频，你将观看它
Or as we just talked about, you could have some kind of thrift RPC server where you pass video frames to this thing and get compressed video back, et cetera. But WebM is pretty epic. It has better compression than H.264. So for people who aren't that familiar if you go on you know YouTube let's say and you watch a video you're gonna watch it
以 H.264 格式，这是由制作 MP3 的人开发的格式，它有一套与之相关的专利，我相信谷歌实际上为他们编码的每个视频向 H.264 的人支付版税，或者有某种谈判，但基本上如果你想以这种格式编码视频，正如 YouTube 所做的那样，你理论上必须付钱，而且你所有的程序，你知道，比如将摄像机连接到电脑并为你压缩视频的程序，它们都必须付钱给这家公司，这有点像敲诈。它还有很多问题。代码本身没有很好的保真度，因为它是闭源的，等等。
in h.264 format which is this format developed by seeing people who made mp3 and it has a set of patents associated with it and I believe Google actually pays the H.264 people royalties for every video they encode or there's some kind of negotiation but basically if you want to encode video in this format as YouTube does you have to theoretically pay money and all of your programs you know say the program that connects your camcorder to your computer and compresses video for you, they have to pay this company money, and it's kind of a racket. There's also a bunch of issues with it. The code itself doesn't have very good fidelity because it's closed source, etc.
所以 WebM 摆脱了所有这些。它是完全开源的。人们能够编辑代码、修复代码、清理代码等。它有一个未优化的版本，它不做各种疯狂的黑客行为。那个未优化的版本可以在任何东西上运行。就像你可以在你的树莓派或甚至你的安卓手机上编码视频。这是 H.264 做不到的。所以至少，嗯，使用帕特里克将要谈论的东西是可能的，但那是一个次要问题。总的来说，即使它是可能的，也有诉讼，围绕它有诉讼问题。所以是的，如果你想做任何与视频有关的事情，一定要看看 WebM。
So WebM gets rid of all of that. It's totally open source. People are able to edit the code, fix the code, clean it up, etc. It has an unoptimized version, which doesn't do all sorts of crazy hacks. And that unoptimized version will run in anything. Like you can encode a video in your Raspberry Pi or on your Android phone even. That's something that's not possible with H.264. So at least, well it is possible using something Patrick will talk about, but that's a side issue. In general, and even if it is possible, there's litigation, there's litigious issues around it. So yeah, so definitely check out WebM if you want to do anything with video.
所以，H.264 之所以非常流行，部分原因是因为它有很多问题，但现在它太普遍了，以至于我认为有很多硬件专门用于加速 H.264 解码，至少是的，在某种程度上还有编码，但你知道，让我们专注于解码，因为想法是你创建一次并多次观看，希望至少对于，你知道，互联网视频或其他什么，是的，嗯，所以，低端手机和平板电脑上有很多硬件，人们专门用来解码 H.264。对。那么 WebM 是否会受苦，比如必须在软件中完成所有这些？
So what is the, so the reason H.264, like part of why it is really popular, and there's a lot of problems with it, but now like it's so ubiquitous that like i think there's a lot of hardware associated specifically with accelerating h.264 decoding at least yeah and somewhat encoding but you know let's focus on decoding because the idea is you create once and watch it many times hopefully at least for you know internet videos or whatever yeah um so like there's a lot of hardware on low end phones and tablets and people to like specifically to decode H.264. Right. So does WebM suffer like have to do all that in software?
它能利用吗，比如那些东西是否足够通用以适用于 WebM？这会损害采用率吗？是的。所以，是的，正如你所说，有用于 H.264 解码的硬件芯片。我不认为有用于 WebM 的硬件芯片，至少我没听说过。所以是的，它会在那个领域受苦。它会消耗你更多的电池等等。目前，他们有点针对桌面。所以如果你看，你知道，两天前在 Google I/O 上有一个关于 WebM 的演示，几乎所有的
Can it leverage like is that stuff generic enough to work for WebM? Is it going to hurt adoption? Yeah. So yes, to your point, there are hardware chips for H.264 decoding. I don't think there are hardware chips for WebM, at least I haven't heard of it. So yeah, it will suffer in that arena. It will use more of your battery and things like that. Right now, they're kind of targeting desktop. And so if you look at, you know, there was a presentation on Google I.O. about WebM two days ago, and almost all
演示都集中在桌面体验上。所以我认为这是你，你知道，在桌面上，他们，你知道，WebM 在各个维度上都更好。所以他们有点，你知道，做那部分，把桌面做好，然后开始在手机上推出 WebM 之类的东西。所以它还有几年时间，但如果你正在开发，如果你正在编写代码，如果你是中型或大型项目的一部分，你可以使用 WebM，在 12 到 18 个月内，手机可能会有硬件支持它。杰森预测。
of the presentation was focused on the desktop experience. So I think it's one of these things you, you know, on desktop, they're, you know, WebM is just better in every dimension. And so they kind of, you know, do that part of it, get the desktop right, and then start to roll out the phones with WebM and things like that. So it's still got a few years out, but if you're developing, if you're writing code, and if you're part of, pretty medium or large-sized project, you could use WebM, and in 12, 18 months, the phones will probably have hardware for it. Jason predicts.
这是我的预测。这是我的摩尔定律。如果它搞砸了你的项目，那不是我的错。但即使在软件中，解码也从来不是一个问题。如果你在看大量的 YouTube 视频，那么是的，使用 WebM 你的电池会受损。嗯，我知道在我的 Nexus 7 上，我有一个视频播放器，它会告诉我它是硬件解码还是软件解码。
That's my prediction. That's my Moore's law. And if he tanks your project, it's not as full. But even in software, decoding is never really an issue. If you're watching tons of YouTube video, then yeah, your battery will suffer using WebM. Well, I know on my Nexus 7, so I have a video player which will tell me if it's on hardware or software decoding.
当它处于软件解码时，它工作得不太好，电池消耗得快得多。哦，真的吗？也许那只是我的感觉。就像一个因素，很难说，我的意思是，我从来没有凭经验测量过它，只是觉得当我看完它时，也许那是心理作用，因为它告诉我它在软件解码，嗯，但是的，我的意思是，我知道这是一个问题，我只是好奇，是的，我的意思是，他们开始，你知道，我知道 YouTube 实际上有一些东西，如果你进入设置，你实际上可以开启 HTML5 模式，这很有意义。
And when it's on software decoding, it doesn't work as well, and the battery drains much faster. Oh, really? Maybe that's just my feeling. Like a factor something it's hard to say i mean i never measured it empirically it just seemed like when i was finished watching it and maybe that's psychological because it's telling me it's on software decoding um but yeah i mean i mean i know this is is an issue i was just curious yeah i mean it would make sense for them to start, you know, I know that YouTube actually has something, if you go in the settings, you can actually put on HTML5 mode.
这是任何人都可以做的事情。我不记得你具体是怎么做的了。在你的 YouTube 设置中的某个地方。然后它将使用 WebM。所以你实际上可以先睹为快，看看一个非……虽然，根据你刚才所说的，你不应该能够分辨出区别，真的，是的，你不会真正注意到，但这只是一件很酷的事情，可以说，是的，我的意思是，这是其中之一，就像理想情况下，也许这听起来在理想主义上更好，我只是，我们将看到，我的意思是，实际上也许它，你知道，它就像一个
This is something that anybody can do. I don't remember exactly how you do it. Somewhere in your YouTube settings. And then it will use WebM. And so you can actually get a sneak peek of what a non... Although, based on what you just said, you're not supposed to be able to tell the difference tell the difference really yeah you won't really notice but it's just kind of a cool thing to do to say yeah and i mean it's one of these things where like ideally maybe this sounds like better idealistically i just like we'll see i mean it practically maybe it you know it's like an
采用问题，就像无论你认为它是对还是错，每个人都使用 H.264，所以有很多同伴压力。对，是的。我的意思是，但正如我提到的，专利问题是一个大问题。是的，确实。如果能摆脱它就好了。是的，如果你正在为一家公司编写软件，并且你正在将软件卖给其他人，消费者或其他公司，
adoption thing it's like regardless of whether you think it's right or wrong like everybody uses h.264 so there's a lot of peer pressure. Right, yeah. I mean, but as I mentioned, the patent thing is kind of a big issue. It is, yeah. It would be nice to get rid of it. Yeah, if you're writing software for a company and you're selling the software to someone else, a consumer or another company,
你将不得不支付这个 Frankenhauser。你将不得不支付大量的版税。所以对于做商业应用的人来说，这是一个严肃的考虑。是的，绝对。好的，好吧，我的本周工具，实际上本周是一个工具，震惊，没人晕倒，是 FFmpeg。
you will have to pay this Frankenhauser. You will have to pay a lot of money in royalties. So for people doing business apps and stuff, it's a serious consideration. Yep, definitely. All right, well, my tool of the week, actually being a tool this week, shocker, nobody pass out, is FFmpeg.
所以类似于杰森谈论视频，我想这是一个很好的关联，编码 MPEG。FFmpeg 是一个开源库，我想可能是最常用的解码视频的库，当你想要在应用程序中播放视频时，各种视频编码，因为我们所有人都到了某个点，你想做点什么。但是，你知道，实际上我过去用它做的是，令人惊讶的是，你知道，有一套可执行文件，他们，你知道，发布来做
So similar to Jason's talking about video, I guess it's a good tie-in in encoding MPEG. And FFmpeg is an open source library, I guess probably the most used one for decoding video, various video encodings for you when you want to play a video in an application because all of us kind of get there at some point where you want to do something. But, you know, actually what I've used it for in the past, surprisingly, is, you know, there are a set of executables that they, you know, release to do
各种格式或原始格式的解码，或者其他什么。但我可以，我发现自己在不同的时间因为不同的原因想要，比如获取一个视频，并从视频中创建所有的帧。所以如果你喜欢暂停视频，像那样，但，你知道，更好，而且你知道，一直以来，因为你可能有一个非常好的视频，你想捕捉一个镜头。现在，显然这些镜头不如用相机拍照那么好，但我想要运行一些图像处理，但我真的不想费心把它连接到解码视频和所有东西的整个过程中。
kind of decoding to various formats or raw formats or whatever. But you can, I found myself in various times for various reasons wanting to like take a video and like create all the frames from the video. So if you like pause the video and like that, but like, you know, kind of better and you know, like all along because you may like have had a really good video and you want to capture a shot. Now, obviously those shots aren't as good as like taking a picture with your camera, but I wanted to run some image processing, but I don't really want to bother hooking it into the whole decoding the video and everything.
那会很好，但如果我能只获取图像并一个一个地做几个，为了那个原因测试它，或者我曾经在 Matlab 中创建了一个小动画，就像一个小，哦，我写出了一些图像，带有一些我正在做的变化，我想把它们串在一起变成一个小视频，这样我就可以给人们看，而不是，哦，只是，你知道，点击每一张图片，FFmpeg 可以为我做这两件事，只需，你知道，在命令行上，我只需运行程序，它就像这个带有通配符的文件，就像把它们全部压缩在一起变成一个视频并编码它们，然后还有另一个，比如
That would be nice, but if I could just get the images and do a couple of them one by one, test it for that reason, or I created a little animation once in i think matlab like a little like oh i wrote out some images like with some variations that i was doing and i wanted to string them together in a little video so i could give to people as opposed to like oh just you know click through each of these pictures and ffmp could do both of those for me with just you know on the command line i just run the program and it's like this file with this wild card just like zip them all up together into one video and encode them and then also the other like
获取一个视频并将它们炸成一堆文件，我知道这听起来很奇怪，你可能以前从未遇到过，我遇到过几次，知道这个项目并知道我可以这样做是无价的，哦，我不知道。你可以用音频做什么？它可以将原始音频转换为 MP3 或反之亦然。它支持，我想，像，像一堆其他音频编解码器。如果你想获取一种格式的视频并将其更改为另一种，
take a video and explode them into a bunch of files i know that sounds weird you maybe you've never come across that before i've come across it a couple times and it's invaluable to know about this project and to know that i can do this oh i didn't know that. What kinds of things can you do with audio? It can convert raw audio to MP3 or vice versa. It supports, I think, like, like a bunch of other audio codecs. If you want to take a video that's in one format and change it to another,
几乎任何格式，它都支持。它非常史诗。是的，很多你用来做这件事的工具，比如开源的，免费的，这些，比如使用 FFmpeg 来做这件事。那是引擎。实际上它们所做的只是帮助你设置参数。是的，完全正确。
almost any format, it will support. It's pretty epic. Yeah, and a lot of the tools that you would use to do that, like open source ones, free ones, these ones, like use FFmpeg to do that. That's the engine. And really all they are is helping you set up the parameters. Yeah, exactly.
这可能会非常令人困惑。是的，是的。这简直是一场噩梦。好的。本期书目。本期书目。所以我的本期书目实际上是一个短篇小说，不是一本书。那不是一本书。
Which can be really confusing. Yeah, yeah. It's a total nightmare. All right. Book of the show. Book of the show. So my book of the show is actually a short story, not a book. That's not a book.
我知道。我作弊了。而且它是完全免费的，我提供的链接直接带你去一个网站，在那里你可以下载这个短篇小说，它非常棒，它是，嗯，所以它的名字字面上是 2b r0 2b，但它真正意味着什么，它有点像英国人的说法，是 to be or not to be。这是一个可爱的故事。我不会透露任何内容，因为，就像我说的，非常短的故事。
I know. I cheated. And it's totally free uh the link i provided uh take you straight to a website where you can download the short story uh it's pretty awesome it's um so the name of it literally is 2b r0 2b but what it really means and it's sort of like the british way of saying, is to be or not to be. And it's a cute story. I'm not going to give anything away because, like I said, very short story.
如果我透露任何内容，你就会知道整个故事。所以这是一个非常有趣的读物。它就像一种科幻反乌托邦主题。而且结尾有一个转折，我觉得很可爱，所以一定要读一读，它只需要 10-15 分钟，它是最近的吗？进入门槛，你知道，我认为它相当老了，好吧，但是，嗯，我以为，你知道，当我寻找新的科幻小说阅读时，我偶然发现了它，而且，嗯，它是，哦，我的库尔特·冯内古特。他写了《第五号屠宰场》。是的，没错。
If I give anything away, you will know the whole story. So it's a pretty funny read. It's like a kind of sci-fi dystopian feature theme. And it's got a kind of twist at the end that i thought was pretty cute uh so definitely give it a read it's only going to take maybe 10-15 minutes is it recent barrier of entry you know i think it's it's rather old okay um but uh i thought you know i came across it when i was looking for new sci-fi stuff to read um and uh it was uh oh my kurt Vonnegut. He wrote Slaughterhouse stuff. Yeah, that's right.
还有其他东西。所以，是的，它非常棒，你们一定要去看看。你只会浪费一点时间。我觉得我现在就要读它，你可以继续说几分钟。是的。有那么短吗？
And other stuff. So, yeah, it's pretty awesome, and you guys should definitely check it out. You only waste a little time. I feel like I'm going to just read it right now, and you can just keep talking for a few minutes. Yeah. Is it that short?
我想大概有五六页吧。好吧，所以也许。好的，我会读得很快。好的，在我去的时候暂停这个。不，我开玩笑的。好的，所以我的书是《密码书》(The Code Book)。所以这是一本非虚构类书籍，但受众广泛，不是教科书，由西蒙·辛格 (Simon Singh) 撰写。
I think it's like five or six pages, maybe. Okay, so maybe. All right, I'll read fast. All right, just pause this while I go. No, I'm just kidding. All right, so my book is The Code Book. So this is a nonfiction but wide audience, not a textbook, written by Simon Singh.
我希望这就是他的名字的读法。这是，他们称这个为什么，比如流行书之类的？不是说它很流行，卖得很多。我相信它卖得很好。但它就像是为普通读者写的，涵盖密码学。所以他采取了一种非常有故事性的方法，用很多，你知道，非常简单的英语来讲述编码事物的历史。它是小说吗？
I hope that's how you say his name. And this is, what do they call this, like a popular book or whatever? Not like that it's popular and that it sells a lot. I'm sure it does. But like it's written for a general audience to cover cryptography. So he takes like a very storied approach in a lot of, you know, very plain English things to the history of encoding things. Is it fiction?
不，它是非虚构的。但就像我说的，它不是教科书，就像它不会教你，你可能不会出来就知道如何做某种基本的编码，但它不会教你，比如编码，但有些，它不会教你，比如，你知道，这是如何安全地编写公钥密码系统，它不像大卫·多伊奇的《现实的结构》，像这些涵盖某种高水平，比如弦理论之类的书，是的，好吧，那会完全像方程，对吧？我会把它等同于像布莱恩·格林的《优雅的宇宙》之类的书，或者其他什么，像这些书，是的，所以
No, it's nonfiction. But like I said, it's not a textbook like it's not going to teach you're not going to you may come out knowing how to do some sorts of like basic coding but it's not going to teach you like encoding but some it's not going to teach you like uh you know here's how to write a public key cryptography system securely it's not like david deutsch fabric of reality like one of these like books that sort of cover something at a high like strength theory at early yeah okay that would be exactly like equations right i would equate it to like brian green's books like the elegant universe or whatever like these kinds of things yeah so
就像他们在写它，所以几乎任何人都可以读它，它非常平易近人，它非常以故事为导向，有很多类比，但这里面有一些非常好的东西，而且，嗯，它相当老了，2000 年，所以它现在已经快 13 年了。但我记得在它最初出版时读过它。我已经有一段时间没读它了，但我记得前几天我偶然发现了什么东西，我就想，哦，我关于密码学知道那个。我就想，我不知道我是从哪里知道的。然后我记起来了，哦，我从这本书里得到了一些。
like they're writing about it so pretty much anybody can read it like it's very approachable it's very story oriented a lot of analogies um but there's some really good stuff in here and um it's rather old uh 2000 so it so it's almost 13 years old now. But I remember reading this closer to when it originally came out. And I haven't read it in a while, but I remember I was coming across something the other day, and I was like, oh, I knew that about cryptography. I was like, I have no idea where I knew that from. And then I remembered, oh, I had gotten some of this from this book.
所以它谈到了古埃及，密码，女王，你知道，想要隐藏秘密信息，然后它在高水平上涵盖了量子密码学，所以同样，不够好到永远，但就像什么是基本思想，而且 13 年了，我肯定它也许不是完全最新的，对于现在发生的事情，但这听起来像是一本好书，就像我认为这些书是人们有争论的，比如它有多大价值，你会用这些知识做什么，但个人而言，而不是仅仅读一本小说，它，你知道，根本不适用，就像读这本书，即使我可能无法，比如去编写加密算法，我可能无法，比如，你知道，实际使用这里的信息，我的意思是，它是一个，背景故事，是的，对于
So it talks about ancient Egypt, ciphers queens you know wanting to hide secret information and then it does cover at a high level like quantum cryptography so again not good enough to ever but like what is a fundamental ideas kind of and being 13 years old i'm sure it's maybe not completely up to date um to what's going on now but that sounds like a good read like i think these books are people have debates like how valuable it is like what would you do with this knowledge but personally as opposed to just reading a fiction book which like you know doesn't apply at all like reading this book even though i may not be able to like go write encryption algorithms that i may not be able to like you know actually use the information in here i mean it's a like background story yeah to the way
事情的方式，我觉得它很有趣，它给你一点点东西去和别人谈论，或者，你知道，只是满足大脑的好奇心，我觉得这在写代码的人中很常见，是的，绝对，它听起来很棒，我的意思是，像这样的书的一个好处是，你知道，我正在读一本小说，正在读《雪崩》(Snow Crash)，你知道，它与编程和黑客技术有很多联系，这种东西，但作为一本小说，我真的不知道它在哪里划清界限，哦，是的，我以前有过这种情况，就像，哦，它说了这个，我不知道这是不是真的，是的，是的，但对于像这样的东西，你有点，你知道，你真的喜欢相信，就像，它试图说真话。
things are and i find it interesting and it gives you like little bits of things to talk to other people about or you know just kind of satisfy the curiosity of the mind which i find common upon among people who write code yeah definitely it sounds awesome i mean one nice thing about books like this is you know i'm reading a fiction book right now reading snow crash and you know it has a lot of ties to programming and hacking and this kind of stuff but being a fiction book I don't really know where it draws the line oh yeah I've had this before like oh it says this I wonder if this is true yeah yeah but with the with something like this you kind of you you know that you really like believe, like, it's trying to tell the truth.
就像，你对你学到的东西感到自信。但与此同时，它不像读教科书。是的，你可以，比如，在晚上或在飞机上或任何地方读它。而且它不像，哦，天哪，我不明白这个。是的，是的。是的，所以我读过很多关于它的书。就像你指出的关于，你知道，宇宙或宇宙学或像这些东西的一些书，而且，嗯，你知道，量子物理学出于某种原因对我来说真的很吸引人，是的，但它就像对，比如我做的任何事情都没有应用，但我，这是我的推荐
Like, you feel confident in things that you've learned. But at the same time, it's not like reading a textbook. Yeah, you can just, like, read it in the evenings or on an airplane or whatever. And it's not like, oh, man, I don't get this. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, so I've read a number of books about it. Like, you pointed out some about, you know, the universe or cosmology or like these kinds of things and uh you know quantum physics especially for some reason is really intriguing to me yeah but it's like no application to like anything i do but i it's my recommendation
我坚持这一点。你是说你没有做量子物理学，我以为山谷里的每个人都做量子，量子，哦，是的，那在我们的隐形初创公司里。我纠缠了我们的听众。哦！现在不知道他们处于什么状态。是的。哦，天哪。你必须写信告诉我们，这样你的叠加态才能坍缩。
i'm sticking to it you mean you're not doing quantum physics i thought everyone in the valley just does quantum quantum oh yeah that's in our stealth starter. I've entangled our listener. Oh! Now it's unknown what state they're in. Yeah. Oh, man. You have to write us and tell us so that your super state can collapse.
是的，完全正确。哦。好的。所以为我们应用人工智能，杰森。是的，应用。所以，你知道，我们……我相信如果你在看，或者如果你按顺序听这个节目，你看到了我们的理论肥皂盒咆哮。
Yeah, exactly. Oh. All right. So apply artificial intelligence for us, Jason. Yes, apply. So, you know, we... I'm sure if you're watching or if you're listening to the show as an order, you saw our theoretical soapbox rant.
是的，如果没有，也许你应该考虑回去听听。是的，我真的不知道哪个顺序更容易。哦，等等，什么？是的，也许你应该并行看。我们应该并行发布这些吗？哦，那会很奇怪。所以这一期将更多地关注细节。所以这里的目标是你在 AI 中能做什么，这将帮助你或你的业务或你正在从事的项目，等等。
Yes, and if not, maybe you should consider going back and listening to it. Yeah, I don't really know which order would be easier. Oh, wait, what? Yeah, maybe you should see it in parallel. Should we release these in parallel? Oh, that would be pretty weird. So this one is going to be more on specifics. So the goal here is what can you do in AI that's going to help you or your business or your project that you're working on, et cetera.
每个人想要在 AI 中做事情需要知道、应该知道的一些事情，以使过程更顺利？至少根据杰森的说法。根据杰森。和帕特里克。是的。和维基百科。而且，是的，多年的经验。我的意思是，我们在一起做 AI 事情已经很长时间了。
What are some things that everyone wanting to do stuff in AI needs to know, should know to sort of make the process go a lot smoother? At least according to Jason. According to Jason. And Patrick. Yes. And Wikipedia. And, yeah, years of experience. I mean, we've been doing AI stuff for a long time together.
对于那些想要投身人工智能领域的人来说，有哪些事情是他们需要知道、应该知道的，从而让整个过程变得更加顺利？至少根据杰森的说法是这样。根据杰森的说法。还有帕特里克的。是的。还有维基百科。而且，是的，多年的经验。我的意思是，我们一起做人工智能相关的事情已经很长时间了。
Well, you happen to have a PhD in it. Well, yeah, I've been doing it for a long time. I took a couple of classes in it. And I watched a video on YouTube. The two of us have been working at the same company for, what, seven years? A long time. A long time. Yeah, like six years.
好吧，你刚好拥有这方面的博士学位。嗯，是的，我已经做这个很久了。我上过几门相关的课，还在 YouTube 上看过视频。我们俩在同一家公司工作了，多久了？七年？很久了。很久了。对，大概六年吧。
Two different companies, but at the same company. Right. Ooh, that was hard. We were at one company together. Now we're at a different company together. Yeah, exactly. But, yeah, we've done a lot of ai stuff we have pretty good experience we want to share with you guys so um so for some common terms in ai so definitions
两家不同的公司，但都在同一家公司。没错。噢，那挺难的。我们曾一起在一家公司，现在我们又一起在另一家公司。对，没错。但是，我们确实做了很多人工智能方面的工作，我们有相当不错的经验想和大家分享，所以，嗯，关于人工智能中的一些常用术语，也就是定义。
yeah yeah so we'll knock these out so first is objective function objective function in a nutshell is like a formal math um function of your target so in other words let's say your goal is to get as many people to click on your website as possible yes pay me money then your objective function is the number of clicks that one okay you might think that might be the way to go like like on your website every time somebody clicks then you your website doing better, right? Yeah, he didn't click their website do works, right? I'm gonna cry
对，对，那我们就把这些过一遍。首先是目标函数。目标函数简而言之就是你目标的数学形式，换句话说，假设你的目标是让尽可能多的人点击你的网站，是的，付钱给我，那么你的目标函数就是点击次数。那个，好吧，你可能会觉得这可能是个好办法，就像在你的网站上，每次有人点击，你的网站就表现得更好，对吧？是啊，他不点击网站就没法运作，对吧？我要哭了。
Another thing is features features are the inputs to your system. So for example You might do the objective function might be will this person click or not click and the features might be You know what you show them. So let's say you're Twitter. So you might show people random people's tweets. You might say someone might go to Twitter and not go on their feed or their friend's feed. They might just go in some kind of discovery mode. I've actually never used Twitter so I'm making this up.
另一件事是特征。特征是你系统的输入。举个例子，你的目标函数可能是“这个人会点击还是不会点击”，而特征可能是你向他们展示的内容。假设你是 Twitter，你可能会向人们展示随机用户的推文。你可能会说，有人可能会去 Twitter，但不看他们的信息流或朋友的信息流，他们可能只是进入某种发现模式。我其实从没用过 Twitter，所以我这是瞎编的。
But they might go in some discovery mode on Twitter where they say, just show me random people's tweets. And so the features would be the person whose tweet they're currently looking at, the text of the tweet, any hashtags written in the tweet. And the objective function would be, did this person follow that person, or did they respond to that tweet, right? If they did, that's good. They did something to increase the volume of content on Twitter.
但他们可能会进入 Twitter 的某种发现模式，在那里他们说：“只给我看随机用户的推文。”所以特征就是他们当前正在看的推文所属的人、推文的文本、推文中写的任何标签。而目标函数就是：这个人是否关注了那个人，或者他们是否回复了那条推文，对吧？如果他们做了，那很好。他们做了一些增加 Twitter 内容量的事情。
So it's like given these number of things to consider, how likely do I think this thing I want to happen will happen? Exactly, yeah. So those are the features. So, you know, there might be, you commonly hear the term hidden features, and that's where there's just aspects of the problem that you didn't you know account for like for example if your only feature is uh you know day of the year or something like that that's your only feature then it's going to take you a year before you can learn anything
所以就像是，考虑到这些需要考量的因素，我想要发生的事情发生的可能性有多大？完全正确。所以这些就是特征。所以，你知道，你经常会听到“隐藏特征”这个词，这就是指问题中你没有考虑到的方面。例如，如果你的唯一特征是“一年中的某一天”之类的，那是你唯一的特征，那么你需要一年的时间才能学到任何东西。
and come back to you know february right or something so you uh you might have hidden features that are oh maybe this person person really likes baseball players, but that wasn't one of your features, so you're not able to learn, you're not able to match the objective function very well. So hidden features aren't something you have, they're something you're missing. Right. But you couldn't necessarily ever have. Right, exactly.
然后回到，你知道，二月，对吧，或者类似的情况。所以你可能有一些隐藏特征，比如“也许这个人真的很喜欢棒球运动员”，但这并不是你的特征之一，所以你无法学习，你无法很好地匹配目标函数。所以隐藏特征不是你拥有的东西，而是你缺失的东西。没错。但你未必一定能拥有。对，完全正确。
There are some features that are just, maybe they're part of the human psychology that you just aren't able to capture. So actually along those lines there is a concept called underfitting or overfitting and so the idea is you know you have this objective function and the objective function has a certain distribution so you want to sort of you want to sort of capture, you want to learn this objective function. So for example, Patrick went on Twitter and he went to this tweet and he clicked on it. So if the next person does exactly what Patrick does, I want my system to learn that it expects a click, right? What can happen is it could memorize exactly Patrick.
有些特征可能只是人类心理的一部分，你根本无法捕捉到。顺便提一下，有一个概念叫欠拟合或过拟合。这个想法是，你知道你有这个目标函数，而目标函数有一定的分布，所以你想捕捉它，你想学习这个目标函数。例如，帕特里克上了 Twitter，他点开了这条推文并点击了它。所以如果下一个人完全照做帕特里克所做的事，我希望我的系统能学到它预期会有一次点击，对吧？可能发生的情况是，它可能记住了帕特里克的所有行为。
Like it could say, okay, if Patrick Wheeler comes to this site and does exactly these three things, then he'll click on the tweet. But under any other circumstance, there won't be any clicks. So it has just memorized the answers. It hasn't really understood the problem. It doesn't realize that some people like athletes and some people like etc so this happens a lot with uh stock market algorithms
就像它可能会说：“好吧，如果帕特里克·惠勒来到这个网站并完全做了这三件事，那么他就会点击这条推文。”但在任何其他情况下，都不会有点击。所以它只是记住了答案。它并没有真正理解这个问题。它没有意识到有些人喜欢运动员，有些人喜欢其他东西等等。这种情况在股票市场算法中经常发生。
yeah people go through the whole history of the stock market and train their algorithm on you know the whole history or whatever but then as soon as tomorrow comes just because like you back tested it but it already had memorized all of history it's like a very naive problem like theoretically people are not supposed to keep doing it but everybody does it it's like you look at the whole history of the stock market then you give it some piece of that from the past and of course it knows exactly what to do it's seen it before yeah but then as soon as you go live with it tomorrow and it sees something it's never seen before it just flips out yeah it does something crazy it wasn't supposed to do yep and so that's called overfitting so that means that you fit the objective function so perfectly but the real world you know what's going to come in the future doesn't fit the objective function
是的，人们研究了整个股市的历史，并用全部历史或类似的数据来训练他们的算法，但一旦明天到来，仅仅因为你进行了回测，但它已经记住了所有的历史。这就像一个非常天真的问题，理论上人们不应该一直这样做，但每个人都这么做。就像你查看了股市的全部历史，然后给它过去的一小部分数据，当然它知道该怎么做，因为它以前见过。是的，但一旦你明天上线，它看到了一些它从未见过的新东西，它就崩溃了。是的，它做了一些不该做的疯狂事情。没错，这就叫过拟合。这意味着你把目标函数拟合得太完美了，但现实世界中未来会出现的情况并不符合这个目标函数。
the future has a different distribution than the past and your algorithm was in general it was very tied to the past distribution and so it doesn't work when you try to predict future things. That's overfitting. The way we deal with that in machine learning is we split the data into two sets. We have what's called a training set and a holdout set. Let's say we do like a 90-10 split. So 90% of our data goes in this training set, and then we train a model-10 split. So 90% of our data goes in this training set. And then we train a model on
未来有着与过去不同的分布，而你的算法通常与过去的分布联系太紧密，所以当你试图预测未来的事情时，它就不起作用了。这就是过拟合。我们在机器学习中处理这个问题的方法是将数据分成两组。我们有所谓的训练集和留出集。假设我们进行 90-10 的拆分。所以 90% 的数据进入这个训练集，然后我们训练一个模型。
that set. And we take the model once it's been trained, and we score it on the holdout set. So this is data that it hasn't seen before. If it does really well on the 90%, but then it fails on the 10% that it hasn't seen, that's a sign that the model has overfit. And so there's various things that you can do to fix this. You can lower some features. Like, for example, let's say I had a feature for every person on Twitter. I had a Patrick feature. I had a Jason feature.
在那个集合上。一旦模型训练完成，我们就在留出集上对其进行评分。这是它以前没见过的数据。如果它在 90% 的数据上表现很好，但在它没见过的 10% 上失败了，那就是模型过拟合的迹象。你可以做各种事情来修复这个问题。你可以减少一些特征。例如，假设我为 Twitter 上的每个人都设置了一个特征。我有一个帕特里克特征。我有一个杰森特征。
I had a you feature for the listener. Then it will use that information. It will memorize something about Jason that it won't apply to Patrick, right? So if I take that feature out of the system to where it doesn't know exactly who's using it and i replace it with something like is the person male or female is the person young or old if i use more general features you can you can sort of address this overfitting problem this is a dangerous thing to get in right because like you can almost accidentally end up
我有一个给听众的“你”特征。那么它就会利用这些信息。它会记住关于杰森的一些事情，而不会应用到帕特里克身上，对吧？所以如果我把那个特征从系统中去掉，让它不知道到底是谁在使用它，并用诸如“这个人是男是女”、“这个人是年轻还是年老”之类的东西来代替，如果你使用更通用的特征，你就可以解决这个过拟合问题。这是一种危险的境地，因为你可能会不小心最终……
training it on the 10 that you're holding out as well so some like people who aren't careful like oh i trained the model on the 90 but then i determine which models to keep and do further tweaking based on the 10 but then you've kind of allowing the 10 to creep in right that's true so then now you're really training on everything and so so when you give even brand new data, it's a delicate balance. And this is where it doesn't come down to a formula. Yeah. Like this is what you do. You keep this much data away and you take this much data.
在你也留出的那 10% 上进行训练。所以一些不小心的人会说：“哦，我在 90% 上训练了模型，然后我根据那 10% 来决定保留哪些模型并进行进一步调整。”但这样你就让那 10% 的数据渗透进来了，对吧？那是真的。所以现在你实际上是在所有数据上进行训练。所以当你给出全新的数据时，这是一个微妙的平衡。这并不是靠公式就能解决的。是的。这就是你要做的。你留出这么多数据，然后取这么多数据。
And it's hard if your data is really expensive or you don't have a lot of it. And then like how you got to be careful. You can't use just you don't have an infinite supply of it yeah so you have very small sample size yeah definitely no it's totally right um so yeah so so underfitting is where you can't even learn on the 90 so in other words you know going back to the twitter example if all i gave you is patrick's age and you had to determine whether he'll click on this baseball link or not, that's a pretty hard problem because there's some... How old are you? You're like 30, 20?
如果你的数据非常昂贵或者你没有很多数据，这就很难了。然后你必须小心。你不能只使用……你没有无限的供应，是的，所以你的样本量非常小。是的，绝对没错。嗯，所以，欠拟合就是你甚至无法在 90% 的数据上进行学习。换句话说，回到 Twitter 的例子，如果我只给你帕特里克的年龄，而你必须确定他是否会点击这个棒球链接，这是一个相当困难的问题，因为有一些……你多大了？你 30 岁，20 岁？
You asked a man his age on a podcast. Anyway, so let's say Patrick is 104. There's probably some 104-year-olds who like baseball and some who don't. And so you're not going to be able to use just someone's age to determine if they will click on a baseball tweet. So you will just not do well on the 90%. That's underfitting. And so that, when you have that problem, then it often comes down to these hidden features. And maybe there's some other part of the problem that you can capture that you're not capturing.
你在播客上问一个男人的年龄。总之，假设帕特里克 104 岁了。可能有一些 104 岁的人喜欢棒球，而有些人不喜欢。所以你不能仅仅通过一个人的年龄来确定他们是否会点击棒球推文。所以你在 90% 的数据上表现不会好。这就是欠拟合。所以，当你遇到这个问题时，通常归结为这些隐藏特征。也许问题中还有其他部分你可以捕捉到，但你没有捕捉到。
So one last set of common terms. There's three basic types of machine learning. There's classification, regression, and control. So classification is kind of how it describes, you know. Like you might say, so even just let's say you want to recommend somebody. You want to say, does Patrick like sports or does he like leisure? Does he like television? You want to fit Patrick into one of these buckets to determine what kind of Twitter user he is.
最后一个常用术语集。机器学习有三种基本类型。分类、回归和控制。所以分类就像它描述的那样。比如你可能会说，即使假设你想推荐某人。你想说，帕特里克喜欢运动还是喜欢休闲？他喜欢电视吗？你想把帕特里克归入这些类别之一，以确定他是哪种 Twitter 用户。
Give me a label. Yeah, exactly. Regression would be if you want to do stock market prediction. That's an example of regression where a know a stock doesn't do you know zero or one there's some continuum of success for a stock and so whenever you're dealing with these continuum you're dealing with regression problems and last is control control is actually very similar to classification you know given a certain set of features in a certain environment, you want to choose one action versus another. The difference is control often involves a feedback loop.
给我一个标签。是的，完全正确。回归是指如果你想做股市预测。这是回归的一个例子，因为你知道股票不是零或一，股票的成功有一个连续体，所以每当你处理这些连续体时，你就是在处理回归问题。最后是控制。控制实际上与分类非常相似，你知道，在给定的环境和一组特征下，你想选择一个动作而不是另一个。区别在于控制通常涉及反馈循环。
So you're doing many classifications, and the results of previous classifications matter. Like you make a move in checkers, the board changes, and the fact that you made that move matters. So you said machine learning there. so how would you define the difference between artificial intelligence and machine learning? Oh man, on the spot. So yeah, so in the past, in the previous episode, we focused on AI in general. You know, machine learning is technically a category inside of AI. There's a lot of, you know, as we mentioned in the podcast, in the previous podcast, there's a lot of intelligence know as we mentioned in the podcast in the previous podcast there's a lot of
所以你做了很多次分类，而之前分类的结果很重要。就像你在跳棋中走了一步，棋盘变了，而你走了那一步的事实很重要。所以你刚才提到了机器学习。那么你会如何定义人工智能和机器学习之间的区别？噢，天哪，突然问我。所以，在上一集中，我们重点讨论了人工智能。你知道，机器学习在技术上是人工智能内部的一个类别。有很多，正如我们在播客中提到的，在之前的播客中，有很多智能……
intelligence which is innate in humans and there's a lot of intelligence which is sort of can be captured you know by human in a program so in the case of in the canonical case that we mentioned image processing of compressing the blue channel that isn isn't machine learning. That's just understanding human physiology, the psychobiology of the brain, and then reverse engineering that. So that would be an example of something that I would consider that AI, but not machine learning. Machine learning is typically where you have a set of data, and you have a set of features and objective function and you want to create a fitness function or another way of saying it is you want to create a model which given new features will create, will try to predict the label for a new training example.
人类天生就有智能，而且有很多智能是可以被人类在程序中捕捉到的。所以，在我们提到的压缩蓝色通道的典型案例中，那不是机器学习。那只是理解人类生理学、大脑的心理生物学，然后对其进行逆向工程。所以那是我认为属于人工智能但不是机器学习的例子。机器学习通常是你有一组数据，有一组特征和目标函数，你想创建一个适应度函数，或者换句话说，你想创建一个模型，给定新的特征，它会尝试预测新训练示例的标签。
So there's typically with machine learning, you're dealing a lot with inputs and outputs and this kind of thing, and not so much with human biology and things like that, although that can get into it. Okay, fair enough. All right, so what are the methods? So you talked about having a model. So, I mean, you've got to get to that model somehow, right?
所以通常在机器学习中，你处理很多输入和输出之类的事情，而不是处理人类生物学之类的事情，尽管这也会涉及其中。好吧，有道理。好的，那么有哪些方法呢？你谈到了拥有一个模型。所以，我的意思是，你必须以某种方式得到那个模型，对吧？
It's like get to this objective, figure out the objective function and take some data. How do you go about doing that? Yeah, definitely. So there's three main methods. There's supervised learning. And so the idea with supervised learning, as the name kind of suggests, you have some sort of supervisor. So imagine if, for example, you know, going back to our Twitter example, Patrick will go to the website and you will either click or not click yeah I might my system might
就像达到这个目标，找出目标函数并获取一些数据。你是怎么做到的？是的，绝对。所以有三种主要方法。监督学习。监督学习的想法，顾名思义，你有一个某种监督者。所以想象一下，例如，回到我们的 Twitter 例子，帕特里克会去网站，你要么点击，要么不点击。是的，我的系统可能会……
predict Patrick's going to click on this tweet and then he doesn't right so we have what's called a residual or an error or my system might predict Patrick's going to click and he does so we have a confirmation right so supervised learning is where you're constantly getting this feedback that you can use to fix your model. And there's many different ways to do supervised learning. There's gradient descent algorithms. There's a perceptron. Then there's back propagation, which back propagation is pretty cool. The idea is you have sort of a set of errors like you told the robot to make a
预测帕特里克会点击这条推文，结果他没有，对吧？所以我们有所谓的残差或误差。或者我的系统可能会预测帕特里克会点击，而他确实点击了，所以我们有一个确认，对吧？所以监督学习是你不断获得可以用来修复模型的反馈。监督学习有很多不同的方法。有梯度下降算法。有感知器。还有反向传播，反向传播非常酷。这个想法是，你有一组误差，比如你告诉机器人做一个……
write and it found out it couldn't make a write so the make a write has an error and then that causes the things which calculated make a write to have an error and the things which calculated those to make an error all the way down to maybe at the bottom you have just sensors and motors and you start learning the errors there and so you can even use things like back propagation to find you know dead pixels in your robot display or if the robot wheel breaks machine learning system can pick up on that and so so that's kind of supervised learning you're constantly getting this feedback now think about checkers for example when you make a move in checkers
右转，结果它发现它不能右转，所以“做右转”有一个误差，然后这导致计算“做右转”的东西产生了一个误差，而计算那些东西的东西也产生了一个误差，一直向下，直到最底层，你可能只有传感器和电机，你开始在那里学习误差。所以你甚至可以使用像反向传播这样的东西来发现机器人显示器中的坏像素，或者如果机器人轮子坏了，机器学习系统可以检测到这一点。所以这就是监督学习，你不断地获得反馈。现在想想跳棋，当你走一步棋时……
No one pats you on the back or kicks you in the face, right? No one says that was a terrible move right like what were you thinking that first move was horrendous, right? checkers you get feedback at the very end and so That feedback at the end is called the reward. that's what in general it's called even with supervised learning but with reinforcement learning you have to estimate the value so you really need to know that first move was that a good or bad move even though i got no you know feedback because you can infer it from the feedback i get at the end of the game
没有人会拍你的背，也没有人会踢你的脸，对吧？没有人会说“那是一步糟糕的棋”，对吧？“你在想什么，第一步太糟糕了”，对吧？在跳棋中，你在最后才得到反馈。所以最后的那个反馈被称为奖励。这在一般情况下被称为奖励，即使在监督学习中也是如此，但在强化学习中，你必须估计价值。所以你真的需要知道第一步是好棋还是坏棋，即使我没有得到任何反馈，因为你可以从游戏结束时得到的反馈中推断出来。
so there's a set of techniques for doing this, reinforcement learning. There's temporal difference learning, there's minimax, Monte Carlo tree search, genetic algorithms, and there's another algorithm called NEAT, which stands for Neuro Evolution of Augmenting Topologies. Of course. Yeah, so you can see these in the show notes. There's a ton of different methods for doing this, but they all kind of are focused on this idea of getting value from reward. And if you think about it in terms of, let's say you're making a website, you might want people to say, let's say you're making the next Amazon. You might want people to buy books from your website. But to do that, to you know get people on your website some of those people will register their credit card some
所以有一套技术可以做到这一点，即强化学习。有时间差学习、极小极大算法、蒙特卡洛树搜索、遗传算法，还有另一种叫 NEAT 的算法，代表“增强拓扑的神经进化”。当然。是的，你可以在节目笔记中看到这些。有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点，但它们都集中在从奖励中获取价值这个想法上。如果你从这个角度考虑，假设你正在制作一个网站，你可能希望人们说，假设你正在制作下一个亚马逊。你可能希望人们从你的网站购买书籍。但要做到这一点，要让人们进入你的网站，有些人会注册他们的信用卡，有些……
will fail at that step right some people will go on to like you know some other part they'll add it to their shopping cart right but but all of these steps have some value like if you add the book to your shopping cart you're probably closer to buying it than somebody else. And so knowing how much closer you are is also a reinforcement learning problem. So in the web domain, there's actually a lot of reinforcement learning. So tell me if I've got an example, correct. So with the checkers example, if I was trying to train my model to replicate a specific human player. Okay. So then supervised would say like say like okay what do you think the player is going to do and then you ask the player to make the move and you say well did you get that
会在那一步失败，对吧？有些人会继续，比如，去其他部分，他们会把它加入购物车，对吧？但所有这些步骤都有一定的价值。如果你把书加入购物车，你可能比其他人更接近购买它。所以知道你有多接近也是一个强化学习问题。因此，在网络领域，实际上有很多强化学习。那么告诉我，我举的例子对吗？在跳棋的例子中，如果我试图训练我的模型来复制一个特定的人类玩家。好的。那么监督学习会说，比如，“你认为玩家会做什么？”然后你让玩家走那一步，你说，“好吧，你猜对了吗？”
move right or not did you guess the move he said so you're super every step you're saying did you match what somebody or something did yep so that's called there's actually a specific term for that it's called heavy and learning is when you have somebody kind of sitting alongside the computer and you make the computer match that person okay but then unsupervised would say or sorry reinforcement and learning would say like okay you're gonna do good or bad win or lose checkers but I don't have a specific human I want you to model I just want you to win right so you only only for sure thing you're gonna know is at the very end if you won or lost exact so you've got to come up with your own
你每一步都在说，你是否匹配了某人或某物所做的事情？对，所以这被称为……实际上有一个专门的术语，叫赫布学习，就是当有人坐在电脑旁边，你让电脑匹配那个人的行为。好的。但无监督学习会说，或者抱歉，强化学习会说，比如，“你会做得好或坏，赢或输跳棋，但我没有一个特定的我想让你模仿的人，我只是想让你赢。”对吧？所以你唯一能确定的就是最后你是否赢了。对，所以你必须想出你自己的……
metric for how well you're doing in the meantime. Yep, that's exactly right. Okay. So one really cool thing about reinforcement learning is there's something called co-evolution. And the idea is you can actually have 10 computers. They can all play each other. And then they can learn from each other's and their own mistakes. And in theory, you could use co-volution to make the perfect checkers player.
衡量你做得如何的指标。是的，完全正确。好的。关于强化学习，有一件非常酷的事情叫协同进化。这个想法是，你可以拥有 10 台电脑。它们都可以互相比赛。然后它们可以从彼此的错误和自己的错误中学习。理论上，你可以使用协同进化来制造完美的跳棋玩家。
You know, it would just keep learning by playing itself and playing its opponents. It would keep, like, making mistakes. Because if two computers play each other, this gets back to our previous podcast where we talked about the two grandmasters and you could sit in between them, right? If two computers play each other, one of them will win and one of them will lose. And if the one who loses can learn something from its mistake, it will eventually win. And now the second one will learn something. If you could follow this process to infinity, then you'd have the world's top player.
你知道，它会通过自己玩和与对手玩来不断学习。它会不断地犯错。因为如果两台电脑互相比赛，这回到了我们之前的播客，我们谈到了两位特级大师，你可以坐在他们中间，对吧？如果两台电脑互相比赛，其中一个会赢，另一个会输。如果输掉的那一个能从错误中吸取教训，它最终会赢。现在第二个会学到一些东西。如果你能无限期地遵循这个过程，那么你就会拥有世界上顶尖的玩家。
There are some caveats to this. So there's something called the red queen effect where it's another way of saying is the rock paper scissors effect you can have three computers and just like rock paper scissors each one can beat another one but there's a cycle those are called like transitive right yeah just because i beat you and you you beat bob and bob beats me now oh crap like no no like so me beating you, you beating Bob doesn't mean I'm better than Bob. Bob could still beat me
这有一些注意事项。有一种叫“红皇后效应”，这是另一种说法，即“剪刀石头布效应”。你可以有三台电脑，就像剪刀石头布一样，每一个都可以打败另一个，但有一个循环。这些被称为非传递性，对吧？是的，仅仅因为我打败了你，你打败了鲍勃，而鲍勃打败了我，现在……噢，糟糕，不，不，我打败你，你打败鲍勃，并不意味着我比鲍勃强。鲍勃仍然可以打败我。
and there's nothing wrong with the universe. Exactly, exactly. And so you get into these Red Queen effects and it actually makes it very hard. So in practice, co-evolved players aren't the best players in the world, sadly. But that's totally possible in theory. And so that kind of makes that alluring.
宇宙并没有什么问题。完全正确，完全正确。所以你陷入了这些红皇后效应，这实际上使它变得非常困难。所以实际上，协同进化的玩家并不是世界上最好的玩家，很遗憾。但在理论上这是完全可能的。所以这让它变得很有吸引力。
So I jumped the gun and I said unsupervised. Because I said supervised and I was like, what's not supervised? Unsupervised. So what is unsupervised then? So unsupervised learning, this is actually pretty hard for me to understand at first. But it's a little bit simpler.
所以我抢先说了无监督学习。因为我说了监督学习，然后我在想，什么不是监督学习？无监督学习。那么什么是无监督学习呢？所以无监督学习，这对我来说起初确实很难理解。但它稍微简单一点。
Another way of thinking of unsupervised learning is just two things, either clustering or dimensionality reduction. Sounds awesome. Yeah, they both sound pretty epic. So, you know, clustering, for example, if you go to, say, Google News and you look up a news article like the Tesla article that we mentioned a couple weeks ago, you'll see this article like North Carolina bans Tesla. And then at the bottom, you'll see 200 similar articles, right? Well, that's because Google News is doing clustering on all the news articles in the Internet.
另一种思考无监督学习的方式只有两件事，要么是聚类，要么是降维。听起来很棒。是的，它们听起来都很史诗。所以，你知道，聚类，例如，如果你去，比如 Google 新闻，你查找一篇新闻文章，比如我们几周前提到的特斯拉文章，你会看到这篇文章，比如“北卡罗来纳州禁止特斯拉”。然后在底部，你会看到 200 篇类似的文章，对吧？嗯，那是因为 Google 新闻正在对互联网上的所有新闻文章进行聚类。
And it's saying, okay, all of these news articles are in the same cluster. Like they're all about Tesla being banned in North Carolina. So that's an example of clustering. Dimensionality reduction is, let's say, for example, let's say you're Twitter and you're trying to capture user behavior. Whether someone is 13 years old or 14 years old, like let's just look at people who are you know providing their ages on their accounts, that might not matter. Like a 13 year old and a 14 year old might behave the same on Twitter, but a 13 year old and a 70 year old definitely don't behave the same, right? So if you think of every possible age as a dimension, so you know a 13 year old a 14 year old two different dimensions where you know someone's either in one dimension or the other
它在说，好吧，所有这些新闻文章都在同一个集群中。它们都是关于特斯拉在北卡罗来纳州被禁的。所以这就是聚类的一个例子。降维是，假设，例如，假设你是 Twitter，你正在尝试捕捉用户行为。某人是 13 岁还是 14 岁，比如，让我们只看那些在账户上提供年龄的人，这可能并不重要。比如一个 13 岁和一个 14 岁的人在 Twitter 上的行为可能是一样的，但一个 13 岁和一个 70 岁的人的行为绝对不一样，对吧？所以如果你把每一个可能的年龄都看作一个维度，所以你知道一个 13 岁，一个 14 岁，两个不同的维度，你知道某人要么在一个维度，要么在另一个维度。
some of those dimensions can be collapsed like you can maybe collapse it down to a preteen teenager young adult middle age and elderly so that's now you've collapsed what's the oldest person let's So now you've collapsed, what's the oldest person? Let's say 120. You've collapsed 120 dimensions down to five. And so that's an unsupervised problem. So you're just taking user behaviors, and you're not trying to predict anything. You're just trying to find out, can I collapse some of this data?
其中一些维度可以被折叠，比如你可以把它折叠成青春期前、青少年、年轻人、中年人和老年人。所以现在你已经折叠了……最老的人是多少岁？让我们说 120 岁。你已经把 120 个维度折叠成了 5 个。所以这是一个无监督问题。所以你只是在获取用户行为，你并没有试图预测任何事情。你只是想找出，我能折叠其中一些数据吗？
Yeah, it's a form of compression almost. So like the classic one with image processing, and you kind of mentioned this with the human eye in a way but like if you have red green and blue for a specific sensor type of activity you're doing but you know that's a lot of data if you have a full you know 64 by 64 of red 64 by 64 you know there's a big array of every color but you find out it turns out you're on Mars. I don't know. And there's a lot of red, but no blue. Yeah.
是的，这几乎是一种压缩形式。所以就像图像处理中的经典案例，你以某种方式提到了人类眼睛，但如果你有红色、绿色和蓝色用于你正在做的特定传感器类型的活动，但你知道如果你有一个完整的 64x64 的红色，64x64 的……你知道，每个颜色都有一个大的数组，但你发现你是在火星上。我不知道。而且有很多红色，但没有蓝色。是的。
So red and green are really the only things that matter from a high level. Blue just basically is always the same value all the way across. So you're kind of wasting data by storing that. If instead you used all those bits you were using to store more red and green information, then you may be better off. Yep. can you kind of reduce those dimension or you just reduce how much you have to store a process and stay close to the original you know almost the same amount yeah definitely so so for both of these
所以红色和绿色确实是从高层来看唯一重要的东西。蓝色基本上在整个过程中总是相同的值。所以你通过存储它来浪费数据。如果你改用所有那些你用来存储更多红色和绿色信息的位，那么你可能会更好。是的。你能以某种方式减少那些维度，或者你只是减少了你必须存储或处理的数量，并保持接近原始数据，你知道，几乎相同的数量。是的，绝对。所以对于这两者……
these end up being the same problem like yes during dimensionality reduction if you think about it's a little bit intuitive that you know the same methods could be used to do either. Clustering is basically reducing down to one dimension, right? So the most common one, and if you make your own Google News site at home, you can use this. You can write the code in four or five lines.
它们最终是同一个问题，就像是的，在降维过程中，如果你考虑一下，这有点直观，你知道相同的方法可以用来做任何一个。聚类基本上是减少到一个维度，对吧？所以最常见的一个，如果你在家里制作自己的 Google 新闻网站，你可以使用这个。你可以在四五行代码中写出它。
It's actually on Wikipedia. Is k-means clustering. This is what everybody does the first time they do some kind of clustering. There's also PCA, which stands for principal components analysis. That's a little bit more advanced and involves a lot of linear algebra. You have to like invert a matrix, transpose, some other stuff. So that's pretty heavy. I'm sure you could find a library to do it if you don't want to tackle that one yourself and then there's a neural gas which is pretty awesome
它实际上在维基百科上。是 K-means 聚类。这是每个人第一次做某种聚类时都会做的事情。还有 PCA，代表主成分分析。那稍微高级一点，涉及很多线性代数。你必须像反转矩阵、转置、其他一些东西。所以那相当沉重。我相信如果你不想自己处理那个，你可以找到一个库来做它，然后还有神经气体，这非常棒。
I think that was from World War I right? No no no, it's mustard gas Oh, nerd gas So yeah, neural gas is basically a little bit complicated but kind of constructs these neural networks and uses this force directed clustering to place the neurons.
我想那是来自第一次世界大战吧？不，不，那是芥子气。噢，神经气体。所以是的，神经气体基本上有点复杂，但构建了这些神经网络，并使用这种力导向聚类来放置神经元。
And, you know, these are kind of an increasing complexity. So if you need neural gas, you probably are doing something pretty heavy. Yeah, I feel like I need to write these words you said down and I'll just go Google them. Yeah, definitely. So this is the kind of episode you want to look at the show notes. And, you know, Wikipedia is awesome at not only telling you about these like we are, but also providing some pretty killer illustrations. I know for Neural Gas, if it's not Wikipedia, it's some other website that's pretty early in the search results. It actually, you can draw a shape on the screen or some Java applet.
而且，你知道，这些复杂性在增加。所以如果你需要神经气体，你可能正在做一些相当沉重的事情。是的，我觉得我需要写下你说的这些词，然后我会去 Google 它们。是的，绝对。所以这是那种你想看节目笔记的剧集。而且，你知道，维基百科不仅擅长像我们一样告诉你这些，还提供了一些相当棒的插图。我知道对于神经气体，如果不是维基百科，就是其他在搜索结果中很靠前的网站。它实际上，你可以在屏幕上画一个形状或一些 Java 小程序。
And the Neural Gas, like, will create a model that fits this shape in real time you'll see all these neurons like going around your shape fitting it's pretty epic yeah i mean the goal of this episode isn't to allow you tell you what lines of code to write to do these things but more like you'll have heard these before or you'll know what to look up if you say oh what was i i have this problem i need to make make two articles and determine if they're like each other or not. What was that thing Jason said? It's like, oh, okay, yeah, I've heard that before. K-means, like, oh, okay, good.
然后神经气体，就像，会创建一个实时拟合这个形状的模型，你会看到所有这些神经元像绕着你的形状拟合，这非常史诗。是的，我的意思是，这一集的目的不是让你知道写什么代码行来做这些事情，而是更多地让你听说过这些，或者如果你说“噢，那是什么？我有这个问题，我需要制作两篇文章并确定它们是否相似。”杰森说的那件事是什么？就像，噢，好的，是的，我以前听说过。K-means，就像，噢，好的，很好。
Yeah, definitely. I mean, at the end of the show, we'll talk about some tools, some open source tools that will make your life a lot easier. But, yeah, definitely we don't want to get too specific because that will just be kind of boring. Yes. Those textbooks are boring. Yeah, yeah, exactly that will just be kind of boring. Yes. Those textbooks are boring. Yeah, yeah.
是的，绝对。我的意思是，在节目结束时，我们会谈论一些工具，一些开源工具，会让你的生活轻松很多。但是，是的，绝对我们不想太具体，因为那会有点无聊。是的。那些教科书很无聊。是的，是的，完全那样会有点无聊。是的。那些教科书很无聊。是的，是的。
We would be even more boring. Yeah. Because we'd also be doing it wrong. We'd still have to go read the textbook. Yeah. Oh, man. So there's lots of challenges. Obviously.
我们会更无聊。是的。因为我们也会做错。我们仍然必须去读教科书。是的。噢，天哪。所以有很多挑战。显然。
Yeah, I mean, this is definitely not a pure science. There's a lot of art. I don't have a robot to clean my house yet. No. That's totally, we should make one. That would be so epic that was last episode yeah true okay so one of the challenges is making an objective function right so let's say you have a website and you have some way of customizing the color scheme and so you want my your objective function to be every time someone clicks a button that's good. And if they come to your website
是的，我的意思是，这绝对不是一门纯科学。有很多艺术。我还没有一个机器人来打扫我的房子。不。那完全是，我们应该做一个。那会非常史诗，那是上一集，是的，真的。好的，所以挑战之一是制作一个目标函数，对吧？所以假设你有一个网站，并且你有某种自定义配色方案的方法，所以你想要你的目标函数是每次有人点击按钮，那很好。如果他们来到你的网站……
they don't click a button, that's bad. So the system might learn make the entire website text everything the same shade of pink and just make one button blue. There's only one thing the user can do is click this button because everything else is completely camouflage. So they might, yeah, everyone who comes to your website will can do is click this button because everything else is completely camouflaged.
他们没有点击按钮，那很糟糕。所以系统可能会学到“把整个网站的文字、所有东西都变成同样的粉红色，只把一个按钮变成蓝色”。用户唯一能做的事情就是点击这个按钮，因为其他一切都被完全伪装了。所以他们可能会，是的，每个来到你网站的人都只能点击这个按钮，因为其他一切都被完全伪装了。
So they might, yeah, everyone who comes to your website will either leave or, like, click this button. A lot of people will probably click the button just because they've never seen a crazy website like that, right? But that, although you maximized your objective function, you clearly, the system didn't do what you wanted, which is make a pleasing website, right? So would it be able to make the hamster dance website? I've never seen the hamster dance website i've never seen the hamster dance website okay sorry anyways that sounds wait describe it sounds pretty epic it's like rows of little animated gif hamsters singing a little song and dancing in unison what really it was like very old website it's like is that around the time i saw the prime number pooping
所以他们可能会，是的，每个来到你网站的人要么离开，要么点击这个按钮。很多人可能会点击这个按钮，仅仅因为他们从未见过那样疯狂的网站，对吧？但那，虽然你最大化了你的目标函数，但你显然，系统没有做你想要的，也就是制作一个令人愉悦的网站，对吧？所以它能制作仓鼠跳舞网站吗？我从没见过仓鼠跳舞网站，我从没见过仓鼠跳舞网站。好的，抱歉，总之，那听起来，等等，描述一下，听起来很史诗。就像一排排小动画 GIF 仓鼠在唱一首小歌，整齐地跳舞。真的吗？那是非常古老的网站，就像，那是在我看到质数拉屎的时候吗？
bear have you seen this no it's a bear that poops prime numbers. That sounds much more intellectual than what I'm talking about. Despite a pooping bear being not sounding intellectual, it's far more intellectual than the Hamster Dance website. But we're really out of... So how is this related to A-B testing? Oh, yeah.
熊，你见过这个吗？不，那是一只拉质数的熊。这听起来比我说的更有知识含量。尽管拉屎的熊听起来并不像有知识含量，但它比仓鼠跳舞网站更有知识含量。但我们真的没时间了……所以这和 A-B 测试有什么关系？噢，是的。
So definitely you want to take your model once you've trained it, and you want to take your model once you've trained it and you want to you know give it to some users and see how they interact with it right so AB testing is where basically you have a new feature it might be a new UI might be new layout right might be a new model of something you've trained which you know changes the text or whatever you want to show it to a small group of your users, and you want to see how their behavior differs from the control group.
所以绝对你想在训练好模型后使用它，你想在训练好模型后使用它，你想，你知道，把它给一些用户，看看他们如何与它互动，对吧？所以 A-B 测试基本上是你有一个新功能，可能是新的 UI，可能是新的布局，对吧？可能是你训练过的某种新模型，它改变了文本或任何你想向一小部分用户展示的东西，你想看看他们的行为与对照组有何不同。
So for example, if you change the color scheme of your website, you might have two websites for a short amount of time, one with the old, one with the new. If people on the new one are clicking on way more stuff, that's a good sign that this new color scheme is the way to go yeah i mean i think with all of these things we talked about like and i guess it falls good under challenges
例如，如果你改变了网站的配色方案，你可能会在短时间内有两个网站，一个旧的，一个新的。如果新网站上的人点击了更多东西，那是一个好迹象，表明这个新配色方案是可行的。是的，我的意思是，我认为我们谈论的所有这些事情，比如，我想它在挑战下很好。
right it's like it's hard like no matter what the model says doesn't mean it's going to be right yeah so like we talked about the stocks again like it's a good thing right just because it shows it's made money in the past you may have made a flaw or just maybe like it's not i don't know it's not up to scruff it's not good enough right know it's not up to scrub it's not good enough right so you know that you can end up when you try it in the real world you don't want to just push it out to everybody you don't want to put all your i wish i had a million dollars all your million dollars in the algorithm on the first day right like that would be silly because you may have messed something up yeah yeah exactly yeah so exactly. Yeah, so same thing. You all just let your algorithm push live
对，就像它很难，无论模型说什么，并不意味着它是对的。是的，就像我们再次谈论股票一样，这是一件好事，对吧？仅仅因为它显示它在过去赚了钱，你可能犯了一个错误，或者只是也许它不符合标准，它不够好，对吧？你知道它不符合标准，它不够好，对吧？所以你知道，当你尝试在现实世界中应用它时，你不想只是把它推给所有人，你不想把你所有的……我希望我有一百万美元……你所有的百万美元在第一天就投入到算法中，对吧？那会很愚蠢，因为你可能搞砸了一些事情。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，所以同样的事情。你们都只是让你的算法上线……
the all pink and one blue button thing. Sure, maybe performance goes up really fast initially and then people never come back to your website because they don't understand what's going on. Yeah, actually that gets a really interesting point, which is your objective function often captures something that is very short term. Like, as we mentioned, people clicking on your website.
全粉色和一个蓝色按钮的事情。当然，也许性能最初上升得很快，然后人们再也不会回到你的网站，因为他们不明白发生了什么。是的，实际上这触及了一个非常有趣的点，即你的目标函数通常捕捉到的是非常短期的东西。就像我们提到的，人们点击你的网站。
It's often something that's very instant. And it has to be. Otherwise, you wouldn't be able to train a model on it. So you have to sort of balance what the model says with your actual business. You might not want people to click on your ads as often as you could, as they could. Like, if you had the system just say, okay, I want people to click on ads. Like, when they click, I want the percentage of clicks on ads to be high. So the system, if you gave it total freedom, would make one ad that was the entire page, and everyone who clicked anywhere on the page clicked on the ad.
它通常是即时的。而且必须是这样。否则，你将无法在其上训练模型。所以你必须平衡模型所说的和你实际的业务。你可能不希望人们像他们能做的那样频繁地点击你的广告。比如，如果你让系统只是说，好吧，我希望人们点击广告。比如，当他们点击时，我希望广告的点击百分比很高。所以系统，如果你给它完全的自由，会制作一个占据整个页面的广告，每个人点击页面上的任何地方都会点击广告。
But that ruins, as you mentioned, the long-term value of your website. And capturing things like long-term value, user retention, in an objective function are extremely difficult. So most of the time, you're sort of balancing the model and the objective function with what you really want as a developer. So that could be a challenge. The way you described it is really interesting because I think a lot of times there's, people tend to think about artificial intelligence, machine learning, they think as like a very like research PhD thing, like trying to build the next humanoid. You know, we talked about like RoboCup, you know, DARPA Grand Challenge.
但这破坏了，正如你提到的，你网站的长期价值。而在目标函数中捕捉长期价值、用户留存等东西是非常困难的。所以大多数时候，你是在平衡模型和目标函数与你作为开发者真正想要的东西。所以这可能是一个挑战。你描述它的方式非常有趣，因为我认为很多时候，人们倾向于认为人工智能、机器学习是像非常研究型的博士那样的事情，比如试图制造下一个类人机器人。你知道，我们谈论过像 RoboCup，你知道，DARPA 大挑战。
We talked about these things in the last episode. And I think people tend to think about those kinds of things, but they forget, like you're saying, you can use this machine learning stuff to help drive traffic on your website at some level or determine what you should do as opposed to just guessing. And maybe not a single guy website. That's probably not the wisest use of time unless he really enjoys it.
我们在上一集讨论过这些事情。我认为人们倾向于考虑这类事情，但他们忘了，正如你所说，你可以在一定程度上利用这些机器学习的东西来帮助增加网站流量，或者决定你应该做什么，而不是仅仅靠猜测。而且对于个人网站来说，除非他真的很喜欢，否则这可能不是最明智的时间利用方式。
But if you get to a certain size website, you really can take advantage of this data if you know what you're doing. Yeah, definitely. I mean, I'm sure a lot of you listeners are familiar with Google Analytics. So it's a product where you can put some JavaScript on your website and you can actually see what's called the user funnel. So you can see people come into your website. You know, 100% of the users visit your website a hundred percent of users who visit visit of that hundred percent some people click on links some people leave right and you can actually see the user funnel like who does what clicks on links and the long tail like who stays on your website for a really long time etc and now they you know you've heard us talk you know
但如果你的网站达到了一定规模，如果你知道自己在做什么，确实可以利用这些数据。是的，绝对可以。我的意思是，我相信很多听众都熟悉 Google Analytics。这是一个产品，你可以在网站上放置一些 JavaScript，然后就能看到所谓的“用户漏斗”。你可以看到人们进入你的网站。你知道，100% 的用户访问你的网站，在这 100% 的访问者中，有些人点击链接，有些人离开，你可以清楚地看到用户漏斗，比如谁做了什么，点击了哪些链接，以及长尾效应，比如谁在你的网站上停留了很长时间等等。现在，你知道，你已经听我们谈论过……
that that is a reinforcement learning problem right you want somebody visits your website for the first time you know they click they're a little bit of reward because you know they're on your website for longer for clicking but there's also potential long-term value right I mean just because you know if they click on one link versus another that second link might get clicked on more often than the first but the first might lead to many other clicks or if you're on YouTube for example one video might be like funny fail video and it's all people falling off slides and that might you know people might watch a video but another video might be part
那是一个强化学习问题，对吧？你希望有人第一次访问你的网站时，他们点击了，这算是一点点奖励，因为你知道他们在你的网站上停留的时间更长，或者因为他们点击了。但这也存在潜在的长期价值，对吧？我的意思是，仅仅因为他们点击了一个链接而不是另一个，第二个链接可能比第一个被点击的次数更多，但第一个链接可能会带来更多其他的点击。或者以 YouTube 为例，一个视频可能是一个搞笑的失败视频，全是人们从滑梯上摔下来的内容，人们可能会看这个视频，但另一个视频可能是烹饪教程的第一部分，人们可能会看完第一部分到第一千部分，结果因为那一个视频而看了大量的视频。
one of how to cook and people might watch part one through 1,000 right watch a ton of videos as a result of that one so even though. And people might watch part one through 1000, right? Watch a ton of videos as a result of that one. So even though someone more people might want to watch a fail video, it still might be better long term value to watch part one of the cooking video. So now you can start to see how reinforcement learning, supervised, unsupervised learning sort of play a role even in modern day businesses. Another big challenge is what's called training serving SKU. So this is a little bit hard to explain but basically you know let's say let's say you're collecting data and let's say you're
所以即使……人们可能会看完第一部分到第一千部分，对吧？因为那一个视频而看了大量的视频。所以即使更多人想看失败视频，从长远来看，观看烹饪视频的第一部分可能仍然具有更好的长期价值。所以现在你可以开始看到强化学习、监督学习、无监督学习如何在现代商业中发挥作用了。另一个巨大的挑战是所谓的“训练与服务偏差”（Training-Serving Skew）。这有点难解释，但基本上，假设你正在收集数据，假设你正在
using people's ages for example. It's very often that there's a bug somewhere in the system. So for example, when I collect everyone's ages and give it to the model, I'm doing it correctly. But then when I try and score the next people who visit the website, their ages are off by a factor of two because of some divide by two error somewhere in the system. So the machine learning algorithm isn't going to tell you like, hey, you have a bug, these ages are half of what I expect them to be. It's going to act literally like those ages are half
使用人们的年龄作为例子。系统中经常会出现某种错误。例如，当我收集每个人的年龄并将其提供给模型时，我做得是正确的。但当我尝试为接下来访问网站的人评分时，由于系统中某个地方的除以二错误，他们的年龄偏差了一个因子。所以机器学习算法不会告诉你：“嘿，你有 bug，这些年龄是我预期的一半。”它会直接把这些年龄当作是一半来处理。
and it's gonna treat everybody like a child. And it's not obvious that there is a bug in your system. So there's many ways of dealing with this. One way to deal with it is to, you know, look at the results. So eventually, you know, if I show Patrick a Twitter tweet and he clicks or doesn't click, that will become part of my training data. Like once you take that action, I'm saying you as Patrick, once Patrick either clicks or doesn't, that ceases to become serving. I've already served that choice to him,
它会把每个人都当作孩子来对待。而且系统中的 bug 并不明显。处理这个问题有很多方法。其中一种方法是查看结果。所以最终，如果我向 Patrick 展示一条 Twitter 推文，他点击或不点击，那就会成为我的训练数据的一部分。一旦你采取了那个行动，我说的是作为 Patrick，一旦 Patrick 点击或不点击，它就不再是服务（serving）了。我已经向他提供了那个选择，
and now he's taking it and actually becomes training. So if I keep my score from there and pass it forward, I can see, like, oh, I thought 90% chance Patrick is going to click, but now at training time I see that there's a 3% chance. So something is buggy in the system you know in general there can be bugs are very hard to isolate. Some other challenges another big challenge is just many of the problems or many of the algorithms are linear like as we mentioned PCA is linear gradient descent
现在他采取了行动，它实际上变成了训练数据。所以如果我保留那里的分数并将其向前传递，我可以看到，哦，我以为 Patrick 有 90% 的几率会点击，但现在在训练时我看到只有 3% 的几率。所以系统里肯定有 bug，通常这些 bug 很难隔离。其他挑战，另一个巨大的挑战是许多问题或许多算法是线性的，正如我们提到的，PCA 是线性的，梯度下降
is linear or can be. Perceptrons are linear. When I say linear, what it means is each feature will get a score, and then all those scores will be added together. So in other words, you know, Patrick is an adult, so adults will click on tweets X percent of the time, and children will click on tweets Y percent of the time. Maybe Patrick's also a male. Males will click Z percent of the time.
是线性的，或者可以是线性的。感知机是线性的。当我说是线性时，意思是每个特征都会得到一个分数，然后所有这些分数会被加在一起。换句话说，Patrick 是成年人，所以成年人点击推文的概率是 X%，而儿童点击推文的概率是 Y%。也许 Patrick 还是男性。男性点击的概率是 Z%。
Wait, maybe also a male? No, Patrick's definitely a male. And males click Z percent of the time. And then it just takes all these features and all the percents and basically adds them up. That's a linear system. So some things just aren't linear. Like, for example, 20 year olds don't click on tweets twice as much as 10 year olds, or at least that's not obvious. Or
等等，也许还是男性？不，Patrick 绝对是男性。男性点击的概率是 Z%。然后它只是获取所有这些特征和百分比，基本上把它们加起来。这就是一个线性系统。所以有些事情根本不是线性的。例如，20 岁的人点击推文的次数并不是 10 岁人的两倍，或者至少这并不明显。或者
100 year olds don't click 10 times as much as 10 year olds, right? So dealing with linearizing the data and, you know, separating, yeah, maybe age instead of being one number from one to a hundred. It's actually a hundred numbers, either zero or one. So somebody age 13, somebody age 14, those are just completely different numbers. That's not obvious. So there's a lot of modeling tricks. And if you go into what's called feature engineering, if you look into this, there's many different tricks that you can do to sort of make your models easier to learn and so
100 岁的人点击次数并不是 10 岁人的 10 倍，对吧？所以处理数据的线性化，以及分离数据，是的，也许年龄不是一个 1 到 100 的数字，而是 100 个数字，要么是 0 要么是 1。所以 13 岁的人和 14 岁的人，这些完全是不同的数字。这并不明显。所以有很多建模技巧。如果你深入研究所谓的“特征工程”，你会发现有很多不同的技巧可以让你更容易地训练模型，从而
to deal with this underfitting problem. So and finally there are kernels. So you know in the case of age, you know that being a teenager and being preteen and being adult like you just you're you're as a human being you know that there's sort of like a fundamental difference yeah like when you are a teenager you're in high school and you have a different let's say mindset and when you're an adult and you're in college or working right so you that's not something that you want the machine to learn that's something that you just know about humanity and you can put that in directly. You can say, you know, is this person in the age bracket, you know, 13 to 18 or not, just based on what you know of the world. And those are called kernels.
解决欠拟合问题。最后还有核函数（kernels）。在年龄的例子中，你知道作为一个人，青少年、青春期前和成年人之间存在根本的区别。是的，比如当你十几岁时，你在上高中，你的心态与你成年后上大学或工作时不同。所以这不是你想让机器去学习的东西，这是你对人类的了解，你可以直接将其放入模型中。你可以说，这个人是否在 13 到 18 岁的年龄段，这完全基于你对世界的了解。这些被称为核函数。
It gets a little bit more complicated than that. There's kernel functions and all this stuff, but in a nutshell, that's kind of what it is, is you taking some part of the problem that you know as a human and applying it to the machine. Interesting. Interesting. Yeah, those are the basic challenges. So we have some tools to help us, some things you can look into maybe to help you out. So one of those we haven't talked about, but natural language processing. And so that would be like, I want to understand not just like okay i see there are words here but what do they they really mean like i want to say this is a verb and this is a noun so
这比这要复杂一点。有核函数和所有这些东西，但简而言之，这就是你将作为人类所知道的问题的一部分应用到机器上。有趣，有趣。是的，这些是基本的挑战。所以我们有一些工具可以帮助我们，一些你可以研究的东西也许能帮到你。其中一个我们还没谈过，就是自然语言处理（NLP）。那就像是，我不仅想理解“哦，我看到这里有单词”，还想理解它们到底是什么意思，比如我想说这是一个动词，这是一个名词，所以
in this sentence so think about like last episode man i guess people really should have listened to last episode we talked about a chat bot right so like in a chat bot you want to recognize the noun of the sentence because you want to repeat the noun back to the person so you know you want to process that language or you know it could even include things up to like you know sentiment analysis or whatever like is the person happy or sad or angry or feeling good you know are you are itunes comments mostly positive or mostly negative so it's got a star rating but people are you know saying bad things also. So like that's kind of,
在这个句子中……想想上一集，天哪，我觉得人们真的应该听上一集，我们谈到了聊天机器人。在聊天机器人中，你想识别句子的名词，因为你想把名词重复给对方。所以你想处理那种语言，或者它甚至可以包括像情感分析之类的东西，比如这个人是快乐、悲伤、愤怒还是感觉良好？iTunes 的评论大多是正面的还是负面的？它有星级评分，但人们也在说坏话。所以这有点像，
they're using bad language. Like, okay. You could combine, well, you go ahead and finish. No, no, no. So one of the, there's actually a lot of packages that do it,
他们在用脏话。好吧。你可以结合……好吧，你继续说。不，不，不。所以其中一个，实际上有很多包可以做到这一点，
but one of them is Open in LP. So by Apache. So don't, if you find yourself doing this, don't like code it yourself. Like don't say like, I'm going to figure out how to do this. Like go find somebody else who already did this. You know, and at least, even if you don't like code it yourself like don't say like i'm gonna figure out how to do this like go find somebody else who already did this um you know and at least even if you don't use it for
但其中一个是 Apache 的 OpenNLP。所以，如果你发现自己在做这件事，不要自己去写代码。不要说“我要弄清楚怎么做”。去找别人已经做好的东西。即使你不用它来做完整的算法部分，至少也要用它来做基础部分，比如分词，识别句子的哪部分是名词，哪部分是动词，帮助你处理这些事情，因为这样你离实现有趣的部分会更近一步。是的，你可以做有趣的事情，比如我们可以获取 iTunes 上的评分，然后说：“OK，使用动词多于名词的人，给我们的星级更低吗？”诸如此类。所以有很多有趣的东西。你可以随着时间推移进行监控，比如我们的星级评分还没下降，但人们在用较少的正面语言来描述我们，
the full algorithmic part of it like at least use it for like the basic parts like segmenting what part of this sentence is a noun and what part's a verb and you know helping you with those kinds of things because you're going to be a lot farther along the path of getting to the interesting parts yeah you do interesting things like we could take the ratings that we got on iTunes and say, OK, people who use more verbs than nouns, did they give us lower stars? You know, things like that. And so there's a lot of interesting stuff. Well, you could like monitor over time, like our star ratings not dropping yet, but people are using less positive language to describe us
那么也许在星级评分开始下降之前，我们就应该担心了。是的，完全正确。所以不要尝试这个，但这就是其中一点，对吧？或者如果你去亚马逊，有时会很困惑，很难，我看评论，它们是低星级的，但人们在说愚蠢的话。我想，如果能找到一种方法来判断人们是在说好话，但却给了低星级评分，那就好了。给那些既给了高星级评分又有非常正面反馈的人不同的权重。是的，绝对可以。我的意思是，你可以将 OpenNLP 与监督学习方法结合起来。
then like maybe we should be concerned even before the stars start dropping yeah exactly so don't try this but like yeah like that's one thing right or if you ever go on amazon sometimes it's confusing right like it's hard for me i look at the reviews and they're like low stars but the people are saying stupid stuff right and it's like okay i don't want you know if you could somehow find like oh i came up with an idea of how to tell that people are saying good things, but giving low star ratings. Like, weight those differently than people who are both giving a high star rating and, you know, really positive feedback. Yeah, definitely. I mean, you could combine OpenNLP with like a supervised method.
是的，亚马逊有“X 人认为此评论有帮助”，你可以在用户发布之前找到某些指示评论是否有帮助的词汇或短语。是的，你可以做各种有趣的事情。我们估计这个百分比的人会觉得这很有帮助。是的，你的评论没有帮助，请不要发布。所以还有两个较低层面的东西。一个是 Mason。我会比较笼统地介绍这个，因为它稍微学术一点。它有一整套不同的进化计算算法。但另一个我会花更多时间介绍的是 Apache Mahout。
Yeah, hi, Amazon has the, you know, X people found this review helpful you could find certain words or phrases which are indicative of a helpful review before the person has even posted it yeah you can do all sorts of fun stuff we estimate this percentage of people will find this helpful yeah your comment is not helpful please do not post it so there's minor two sort of lower level things. One is Mason. I'll cover this one kind of loosely because it's a little bit more academic. But it has a whole cornucopia of different evolutionary computation algorithms. But another one, which I'll spend a little bit more time on, is Apache Mahoot.
Mahout？Mahout。我不知道那是什么。是 Mahout 吗？我觉得那是一个印度词之类的，对吧？没关系。我查一下，你可以继续。但是的，Apache Mahout。我们谈过 Hadoop。
Mahoot? Mahoot. I don't know what it is. Is it Mahoot? I think it's like an Indian word or something, isn't it? That's okay. I'll look it up and you can continue. But yeah, Apache Mahoot. We talked about Hadoop.
骑大象的人。哦，原来如此。所以我们过去谈过 Hadoop，这是一种处理海量数据的方法。而 Mahout 是建立在 Hadoop 之上的机器学习系统。
A person who rides an elephant. Oh, there we go. So we talked about Hadoop in the past, which is a way to deal with massive amounts of data. And Mahoot is a machine learning system built on top of Hadoop in the past, which is a way to deal with massive amounts of data. And Mahoot is a machine learning system built on top of Hadoop. So if you have, say, the whole internet or a ton of data, like every time someone visits your website and moves their mouse or does anything, you're collecting that data and you have terabytes and terabytes of data, you want to be using Apache Mahoot. And it's pretty awesome.
所以如果你有整个互联网或者大量的数据，比如每次有人访问你的网站并移动鼠标或做任何事情，你都在收集这些数据，你有数 TB 的数据，你就应该使用 Apache Mahout。它非常棒。
Actually, a number of people I know are contributors to this project. And the people who contribute to Mahout, it's definitely really well done. It's done by a bunch of really smart people. That's because it's you and your friends? Well, it's not me. I haven't contributed yet. But it's a phenomenal library. I't contributed yet. But it's a phenomenal library. I have used it. And it's great. I highly recommend using Mahoot. And another thing about Mahoot,
实际上，我认识的一些人是这个项目的贡献者。Mahout 的贡献者们，它确实做得非常好。它是由一群非常聪明的人完成的。那是因为是你和你的朋友吗？嗯，不是我。我还没贡献过。但它是一个了不起的库。我用过它。它很棒。我强烈推荐使用 Mahout。关于 Mahout 的另一件事是，
a lot of companies are using it. So it's something that if you get familiar with, you could apply it in industry like almost immediately. Yeah, and we talked about it before. But like, and this is much more in machine learning probably than in artificial intelligence although the two are kind of closely tied i guess but you know this big data thing you always hear about right like i mean a lot of that is ultimately walmart wants to collect all this data about how much people are buying you know based on what input parameters and they just want to measure everything because they don't know what's useful or not but then it's not just a simple problem of like what machine algorithm learning what what machine learning algorithm to apply but like actually doing it right so even like you know my role like i don't do a lot of actual ai or machine learning stuff per se that
很多公司都在使用它。所以如果你熟悉它，你可以几乎立即将其应用到工业界。是的，我们之前谈过。这更多是在机器学习领域，而不是人工智能领域，尽管两者联系紧密。但你总是听说的大数据，很多最终都是沃尔玛想要收集所有关于人们购买多少的数据，基于什么输入参数，他们只是想衡量一切，因为他们不知道什么是有用的。但这不仅仅是应用什么机器学习算法的简单问题，而是要正确地去做。所以即使像我的角色，我本身不做很多实际的 AI 或机器学习工作，
that's not my job but i help the people who do because i go ahead and do a lot of the number crunching and scalable processing that implements what they do so they say hey i came up with this thing or i want to do this model but the data is not in a good format or it's too much so i'll go in and help them like reduce that data you know make sense of that data a little bit better so that they have an easier time and so even if you don't say, well, you know, I don't think I'm going to end up, you know, being a machine learning person or, you know, I don't feel like that stuff's interesting to me. There's still a lot of interesting work to help those people out. You can work with those people, you know, and help them,
那不是我的工作，但我帮助那些做这些工作的人，因为我负责进行大量的数字运算和可扩展处理，实现他们所做的事情。所以他们说：“嘿，我想出了这个东西，或者我想做这个模型，但数据格式不好，或者数据量太大。”我会进去帮他们减少数据，更好地理解数据，让他们更轻松。所以即使你不认为自己最终会成为一名机器学习人员，或者觉得这些东西不感兴趣，仍然有很多有趣的工作可以帮助那些人。你可以与他们合作，帮助他们，
and it's still not, you know, you're not doing it yourself. But it's good to know, like, that this is why they're doing that thing or this is what they mean when they say they're making a model. Yep. One cool thing, too, about Mahout is they have tutorials, and the tutorials actually let you do stuff that matters. They actually have a tutorial where they've given, they've scraped the Internet of a bunch of news articles,
虽然不是你自己做，但了解他们为什么要这样做，或者当他们说正在制作模型时是什么意思，这很好。是的。关于 Mahout 的一件很酷的事情是他们有教程，这些教程实际上让你做一些有意义的事情。他们确实有一个教程，他们抓取了互联网上的一堆新闻文章，
and in the tutorial you'll actually classify the news articles into sports and some other clusters. You make me want to go do this. this yeah you will actually have something tangible if you go through their tutorial which is not very common maybe I'll just stick with processing it it's pretty awesome highly recommend you guys checking it out I would like to learn more about that I guess is like a very broad subject like you could spend your whole career learning any just one of these things and that being your thing yeah definitely so but there's something to be said too for learning
在教程中，你实际上会将新闻文章分类为体育和其他类别。你让我很想去试试。是的，如果你完成他们的教程，你实际上会得到一些有形的东西，这并不常见。也许我还是坚持处理数据吧。它非常棒，强烈推荐你们去看看。我想了解更多，我觉得这是一个非常广泛的主题，你可以花整个职业生涯去学习其中任何一个东西，并将其作为你的专长。是的，绝对是。但学习何时不应用某些东西也很有意义。
when not to apply something yeah so sometimes i think and maybe that's like what we've learned today on this show no no just like today versus like in the past is like learning restraint yeah that like it's not necessarily true that artificial intelligence and machine learning will solve every problem today you know or like throwing it at it's not necessarily true that artificial intelligence and machine learning will solve every problem today. You know or like throwing it at it isn't necessarily the
是的，有时我认为，也许这就是我们今天在节目中学到的，而不是像过去那样，就是学会克制。是的，人工智能和机器学习并不一定能解决今天的所有问题。或者说，盲目地使用它并不一定是
right answer. It's not a silver bullet or a magic bullet. Right. It's another tool in the tool bag like we talk about programming
正确的答案。它不是万灵药或魔法子弹。对。它是工具包中的另一个工具，就像我们谈论编程语言也是工具包中的工具一样。
languages are also tools in the tool bag. Yeah. So it comes full circle. Well I think that's it for this episode. Yeah.
是的。所以一切又回到了原点。我想这一集就到这里。是的。
Some pretty heavy stuff. We're going to try and cover a language. It's been a little while since we've done that. So we'll cover a language next episode. English. I think we can both cover that sufficiently.
一些相当沉重的内容。我们打算尝试涵盖一种语言。我们已经有一段时间没做过了。所以我们下一集会涵盖一种语言。英语。我想我们俩都能充分涵盖它。
Okay, good. I've been coding in English for a long time. I don't know about that. I've been speaking English for a long time. Oh, they're not the same? I'm not sure. Anyways, before we bore you guys, if we haven't watched it already, thanks for sticking with it
好的，很好。我用英语编程很长时间了。我不确定。我讲英语很长时间了。哦，它们不一样吗？我不确定。总之，在我们要让你们感到无聊之前，如果我们还没看完，感谢你们坚持看完。
and have a good one alright see you later the intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution
祝你们过得愉快，好的，回头见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名下发布的。
share alike 2.0 license you're free to share, copy, distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide
相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须提供
attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。